CALL THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE ONE TO
ORDER- AND I HAVE SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT TODAY'S
PROCESS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS TO SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. ARE WE ARE AND ALL
MEMBERS WILL BE PRESENT- TODAY
ARE THERE NOT QUITE YET BUT THEY
WILL BE HERE AT THE TIME WE
START TAKING TESTIMONY. OF THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK BY ACID
EVERYTIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING.
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INTO THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT IS BEING DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW I CAN SEE IT.
ARE TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THAT'S. 877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. THAT SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE IN
ORDER COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE TEN ZERO. PUT A PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LONG NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LONG
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED OR
MAKE A JUDGMENT WHEN WE GET TO
PUBLIC COMMENT OF HOW MUCH TIME
WE HAVE LEFT AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE AS TO.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A ONE
MINUTE LIMIT OR LESS. BUT TODAY
IS THE NINTH OF NINE HEARINGS
ACROSS FEBRUARY AND EARLY MARCH.
OF FOR THIS SUBCOMMITTEE ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION ISSUES. IN TODAY'S
HEARING. WE HAVE FIVE DISCUSSION
ISSUES BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT FOCUS ON
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH- ITEM NUMBER ONE AND
I SHOULD JUST MAKE A COMMENT
THERE ARE FOUR. ISSUES IN ITEM
NUMBER ONE WILL HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT PANELS AND THEN ON THE
FOURTH ONE- WE MIGHT ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
COMMENT. ON THAT THAT IS AN
INFORMATION DISCUSSION ITEM
THERE'S NOT A FORMAL PANEL WHERE
THERE IS THE OTHER ITEMS SO WILL
WILL DECIDE OF WHAT TO DO WHEN
WE GET TO THAT. SO RIGHT NOW
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE ONE A THE
GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND WE
HAVE A LIST MY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MICHAEL
HOW FERRIS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND PETE CALLAS
THE DIRECTOR OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION.
SKEWS ME AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER SO LET ME WELCOME A LIST
MIGHT TO THE SUB COMMITTEE. THE
MORNING UNLESS MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS DISRUPTED NORMAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE PATTERNS
IN MANY WAYS AND IMPACTED THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER PLANS OF MANY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AGE FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR. RECENT REPORTS
HAVE INDICATED THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS CAUSED MANY ELEVENTH AND
TWELFTH GRADERS TO ALTER THEIR
POST SECONDARY PLANS FOR REVISED
THEIR EMPLOYMENT ASPIRATION. AT
THE SAME TIME NUMEROUS SECTORS
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY INCLUDING
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRIES HAVE NOTED
SHORTAGES IN THE AVAILABILITY OF
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES. TO
ENHANCE AND EXPAND THE OFFERING
OF SEAMLESS PATHWAYS FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND CAREER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PATHWAY PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE FIELD OF
TECHNOLOGY HEALTHCARE EDUCATION
AND CLIMATE RELATED FIELDS- AND
THEY WOULD BE LISTED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE GOLDEN
STATE PATHWAYS PROGRAM. THE
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO AWARD TWO
TYPES OF COMPETITIVE GRANTS
ELEAZAR ONE WOULD BE A
CONSORTIUM DEVELOPMENT AND
PLANNING GRANT TO SUPPORT
COLLABORATIVE PLANNING AND THE
OTHER WOULD BE AN IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT. BONDS ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN AND AS A CONDITION
FOR RECEIVING A GRANT. UNDER
THIS PROGRAM- LEDS HAVE TO
IDENTIFY AND SET ASIDE FUNDING
WAS IN ITS OWN BUDGET OR OBTAIN
FUNDING COMMITMENTS FROM PROGRAM
PARTNERS TO SUSTAIN THE ONGOING
OPERATIONAL COSTS. REAL BILL
LANGUAGE INCLUDES PROVISIONS TO
ALLOW FOR THE CONTRACTING OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AND PROGRAM EVALUATION IS
REQUIRED AFTER JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TO BE
COMPLETED BY JUNE THIRTIETH. OF
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND I. WILL
BE BACK LATER FOR QUESTIONS AND
ALL MOMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WILL MOVE ON TO MICHAEL R.
FERRIS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OF THE PUBLIC TO
DO SO ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ALL
PROPOSALS AN ISSUE ONE. OF WILL
FOCUS ARE COMMON THINGS ITEM IN
JUST A FEW CLICKS SHE CONCERNS.
ALSO REGARDING THE GOLDEN STATE
PASSED THIS PROPOSAL OUR FIRST
CONCERN IS THAT IT WOULD ADD
MORE COMPLEXITY TO THE STATE'S
APPROACH THE FUNDING COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS. THE PROPOSAL
HAS SEVERAL ELEMENTS THAT ARE
SIMILAR TO THE STATE'S TO
EXISTING HIGH SCHOOL CTE
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER THE PROGRAM
HAS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS.
SUCH AS HAVING PATHWAYS TO BE
ALIGNED WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS OF COURSE
REQUIREMENTS. AND REPORTING
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH-
INTEGRATED SUPPORT SERVICES.
THAT COULD BE BENEFITS TO
ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS OF THIS TYPE AS A
COMPRISES MOSTLY GREATER OPTIONS
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE
YOU SCHOOLS OFTEN OPERATING
PROGRAMS AT THREE DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF FUNDING AND THREE
DIFFERENT PROGRAM RULES. THIS
CAN MAKE IMPLEMENTING WILL. WE
HAVE THE MINISTRY THE- GONNA
REALLY FISCAL TIMES FOR A SCHOOL
. ARE SO CONCERN IS THAT I THE
PROPOSED EXPECTED. FOR THE TYPE
OF PATHWAY PROGRAMS THAT
RECIPIENTS MUST DEVELOP. AND
ALSO REQUIRES A GRANT TO SUBMIT
A- SET OF. OUTCOME DATA. ELECT
SOME CRITICAL DETAILS AND LEAVES
A FEW KEY DECISIONS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IN THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. SUCH AS THE
FUNDING AMOUNT THAT GRANTEES
WILL RECEIVE IN THE ALLOWABLE
USES OF THE FUNDS. WITHOUT THESE
DETAILS IT IS DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS THE
PROGRAM'S POTENTIAL BENEFITS. A
RELEASE THESE CONCERNS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTED MINISTRATION PRIDE
MORE INFORMATION OF THE PROPOSAL
PRIOR TO THE REVISION. MANY OF
THESE QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO YOUR AGENDA.
FOR THIS SUMMER QUESTIONS IS ON
pBOTTOM OF PAGE SIX. OH ONE OTHER
CONCERN WE WANT TO RAISE. THE
PROPOSAL IS A LITTLE TO TARGET
FUNDING TO SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS-
BENEFIT THE MALLS. THE
MINISTRATION GIVES PRIORITY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH AT LEAST HALF OF
THEIR STUDENT POPULATION
CONSISTING OF ENGLISH TERMS FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS. AMONG OTHER
METRICS- BUT JUST ON THAT ONE
METRIC OF THE PROPORTION OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE YASSER LOW
INCOME. WE FIND THAT AT LEAST
TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MEET THE THRESHOLD FOR PRIORITY.
SUCH A BROAD DEFINITION IS
UNLIKELY TO HAVE MUCH EFFECT ON
STUDENTS. THAT COULD BENEFIT
MOST FROM THE PROGRAM. IF THE-
ADOPTS A PROPOSED WE WERE OTHERS
. CAN WAYS TO TARGET TO. AND
STUDENTS WITH HIGHEST. FOR
EXAMPLE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER INCREASING THE
THRESHOLD FOR PART PRIORITY FOR
DISTRICTS WITH 75% OF THEIR
STUDENT POPULATION BEING ALL
INCOME. FOR INVESTORS STUDENTS.
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO REQUIRE
GRANTEES TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY WILL BE IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS EQUITABLY ACROSS
VARIOUS WILL FACE IN THE WAY
THAT IS TARGETED TO BENEFIT
STUDENT SUBGROUPS WITH LOWEST
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS.
OUTCOMES ON THE COMPUTER COMES
ON THIS ITEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN MOVED TO
PICK QALISYA DIRECTOR OF CAREER
AND COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MORTGAGOR LEARN OF
THE COMMITTEE AGAIN MY NAME ST.
DIVISION RIGHT OF THE CURRENT
CULTURE. VISION HE- TODAY I'M-
ON BEHALF THE STATE'S. OF PUBLIC
pINSTRUCTION CHUNK BERMAN. CITY
IS GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COLLEGE OR CAREER
PATHWAYS. THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
LANGUAGE IN THE GOLDEN STATE
PATHWAYS HAS MANY SIMILARITIES
TO LANGUAGE WITHIN. THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA. PARTNERSHIP ACADEMY
PROGRAM. XIAOMI PRO IS VILLAGE
ALL FORTY SHOULD GO FORWARD
FIVE. IT IS A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
IS FOCUSED ON INTEGRATED COURSES
ACROSS SPECIFIC PROPER PATHWAYS
STUDENTS ROLE IN CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES HAVE
HIRED. A THREE G. COMPLETION
RATE THAN THE STATE AVERAGE AND
HIGHER GRADUATION RATE THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED OPPORTUNITIES FURTHER
DISCUSSES SUSTAINABILITY PLAN.
FOR THE GOLD STATE PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I KNOW THAT AND ONE DAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO A DISCUSSION
OF THE COMPARISON. OF BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION OF
FINANCE ON THIS ONE NOW. AND MY
QUESTION IS THIS IT IS
RECOMMENDED TO BE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION OF ONE NINE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS. THAT WOULD
BE SPREAD OVER FIVE YEARS. R.
WHY NOT TAKE THE AMOUNT OF THAT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION THAT
WOULD BE EXPANDED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND TAKE THE OTHER ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS AND MEET SOME OF THE NEEDS
THAT WE'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
TESTIMONY ABOUT SUCH AS BY DOWN
OF PERSONS STIRRERS- OLD OR
FACILITIES OR OTHER THINGS THAT
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS WHY WAS
IT DECIDED TO TAKE. ONE POINT
FOUGHT TO RECOMMEND ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF ONE TIME
MONEY OVER FIVE YEARS RATHER
THAN JUST WHAT WE NEEDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND USE THE REST OF
THE MONEY FOR. FOR PRESSING
NEEDS. SURE I'VE CHAIR CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH THE PART OF PLAIN
. YEAH TO THE ISSUES THAT YOU
NOTED STIRS- CALLS AS AS
FACILITY CULTURE FUNDED BY
GENERAL- AND HOW OF THE BROWSER
NINETY- WE ARE LOOK AT THE IN
THE AS YOU KNOW BEING CRITICAL
TO SUPPORTING OUR OVERALL
FRAMEWORK- FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW
PREPARING OUR STUDENTS PREPARING
THEM FOR. COLLEGE OPPORTUNITIES
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES IN HIGH
NEEDS CRITICALLY NEEDED AREAS OF
THE STATE BECAUSE WE'VE ALSO
HEARD YOU KNOW FROM OUR OUR
EDUCATORS OF THEIR STAFFING
SHORTAGES FOR TEACHERS FOR OTHER
PROFESSIONAL IF I CAN INTERRUPT
FOR A SECOND WE'RE NOT ARGUING
THAT WERE IN AGREEMENT ON THAT
THIS IS A FISCAL QUESTION NOT A-
NOT A PROGRAM QUESTION. A. N. DO
SEIZED ON THE PER STORES THERE'S
OTHERS THAT ARE FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES THAT ACTUALLY FIT
THIS THE QUESTION IS WHY TAKE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION AND PUT
IT OVER FIVE YEARS RATHER THAN
JUST THE AMOUNT THAT'S NECESSARY
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND USE AN
EXTRA BILLION FOR FACILITIES OR
ONE OF THE OTHER NEEDS TO SELL
TROUBLE FOR PROPOSITION. NINETY
EIGHT THAT'S THE QUESTION. YEAH
YEAH AND I THINK WHAT I WAS SAY
JUST. FACILITIES SOME FIRST
STRIVE NOT BEEN FUNDED BY. THE
GUARANTEED BEEN FUND OUTSIDE
APPEARANCE. IS ONE POINT BILLION
YEARS PROP NINETY EIGHT. OF
RESOURCE. CURRENT THAT WAS THE
QUESTION O IT. WORKERS SINCE
I'M NOT GONNA. A CLEAR ANSWER
LET ME JUST MAKE THE STATEMENT
THAT WE WOULD LOVE THAT YOU GO
TO MAY. TO CONSIDER THE OTHER
NEEDS FOR THE ONE TIME FUNDS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE FOUND THIS
BUT MAKE SURE WE FUNDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY OF USING THE ONE
TIME FUNDS FOR OTHER THINGS. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE ONE EIGHT THAT COMES FROM.
THE COMMITTEE- SENATOR MANCHIN
AGAIN THIS WEEKEND- OUR LIFE.
WELL WE'RE GONNA ANNOUNCED THE
BEGINNING THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
ONE A ONE B. ONE C. ONE G. BUT-
M. ONE C. IS DIFFERENT THAN ONE
A. AND ONE B. ONE G. COMPARES
THE MALL SO I THINK THAT WE
MIGHT ASK A FEW QUESTIONS ALONG
THE WAY. BUT EXPECTED OUR
DISCUSSION. MIGHT ALSO BE UNDER
ONE DAY. THEN I SENT MEANT. I
GUESS THE QUESTION I FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALTHOUGH-
I THINK THAT- FROM EDUCATION
PUBLIC ANSWERED AS WELL- THIS IS
A PRETTY AMBITIOUS PROPOSAL AND-
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I GUESS. THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS WAS THIS
PROPOSAL SOMETHING THAT WAS
DRAFTED AND DEVELOPED BY THE
COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR OR THE
SYSTEM. OR WAS THIS CREATED BY
THE PARDON OF FINANCE- AND I ASK
THAT IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT. WHETHER WE HAVE
THE DEMAND I MEAN WE DON'T AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS. WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SIGNS OF POTENTIALLY DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN OUTLAY OF THIS SIZE I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS IT
APPROPRIATE. DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
GIVEN THE FACTS ON THE GROUND.
AND I'M I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
THE CCC'S WERE SAYING. I GUESS I
GUESS THE SIMPLE QUESTION IS
THIS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE WAS
THIS SOMETHING WAS THIS DETAIL
PROPOSAL SOMETHING WAS DEVELOPED
PRIMARILY BY CCCS. OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ALL CAME UP
WITH. THIS PROPOSAL DEVELOPED IN
AN TRY AFTER THE- OKAY AND WAS
IT IN CONSULTATION OF THE CCC'S
. WE CERTAINLY THANK YOU STATE
OF THE PREVENTABLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY CULTURES- AND WORK
WITH THEM ON NUMEROUS PROPOSALS
BUT NO THIS WAS NOT SPECIFICALLY
ATTRACTED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND SO
I GUESS THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THAT THEN IS- D. DO YOU SEE THAT
THERE'S A NEED FOR THIS I MEAN
WHAT WHAT'S THAT ONE OF THE
FACTS ON THE GROUND THAT YOU
WOULD SAY JUSTIFY THIS TYPE OF
SIGNIFICANT OUTLAY. I THINK WE
SEAT. YOU HAVE REALLY TWO ISSUES
ONE BEING. I NEED TO HAVE A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
AND IN SEVERAL INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE ARE DISPLAYING- THAT ARE
DISPLAYING STAFFING SHORTAGES AS
WELL AS- YOU KNOW CONSISTENT
WITH THE OUR OUR PROPOSED BROAD
GOAL OF. HAVING 70% DEGREE
ATTAINMENT YOU KNOW IMPROVING
OPPORTUNITIES IN COLLEGE GOING
CULTURE TO HAVE MORE STUDENTS
YOU KNOW HOW THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FROM HIGH SCHOOL TRANSITIONING
OVER INTO OUR COLLEGE SYSTEM
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
SHARE THOSE GOALS BUT IF THE
FACT IS IF PEOPLE DON'T ACTUALLY
ATTEND THESE CLASSES OR THESE
PROGRAMS- THEN WE'RE JUST
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY FOR NO
GOOD PURPOSE SO. I DEFINITELY MY
MAIN CONCERN ABOUT THIS- AND IT
REALLY IS CONCERNING TO ME THAT
THIS WAS DRAFTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. NOT IN RESPONSE
TO A PARTICULAR QUESTION REQUEST
BY CCC- WHICH I THINK SHOULD BE
THE PROPER ORDER OF THINGS AND
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULD BE-
RECKLESS WITH THAT I THINK ALL
OF OUR BUDGETARY DECISIONS OUGHT
TO BE GROUNDED IN- YOU KNOW
FACTS ON THE GROUND AS I SAID IN
AND IT CONCERNS ME THAT. AT THIS
APPEARS TO BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
GUYS CAME UP WITH I'M NOT SURE
THERE'S A JUSTIFICATION FOR IT
AND IT'S CENTER WHERE THE CHIRLA
POINTED OUT. THERE ARE A LOT OF
NEEDS RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE COULD
BE ALLOCATING THOSE FUNDS TO
INSTEAD COBB BUT I WILL RESERVE
JUDGMENT UNTIL WE- I GUESS SEE
MORE DETAILS THANK YOU. AND LET
ME SAY ONE THING IN DEFENSE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HE
JUST TO FIND THE CCC ACRONYM AS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THAT WAS
VERY GOOD BECAUSE I'M SURE
PEOPLE AT HOME THOUGHT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. IT IS OCHO
BUG IT. JUST ONE REALLY QUICK
BUT WHAT IF WE DO FIND THE
PROGRAM IS THIS TIME I KNOW THAT
THEIR OTHER PER THERE ARE
CURENTLY ADDRESSING THE- THE
NEW CAREER STANDING AREAS AND
I'M JUST IN CASE WE DIDN'T FIND
. SORRY I THINK YOU'RE GOD
SOMEBODY ELSE'S. LIFE EXPECT
BOTH IN MY PHONE. ALL WANT WHEN
YOU'RE YOUR. SO I'M JUST GONNA
WHAT WHAT WHY OR. FIFTY SO I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORT TO
REMIND ALL SO IT'S NOT MINE. MY
NOT. TO TRY TO SEE IF MAYBE HE'S
RESTARTING AT OKAY. SO I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORT-
CURRENTLY LOCALLY WITHIN
DISTRICTS- OUTSIDE OF OUR
TRADITIONAL- COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT THAT ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF. I TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF DIFFERENT CAREERS
WITHIN THEIR REGION. AND R. O.
B. PROGRAMS- AS AN EXAMPLE OR
PRIVATE SCHOOLS- THAT ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES CAREER
TECH- COLLEGES. IS THIS FUNNY
SUPPOSED TO GO TOWARDS THESE ARE
CURRENT PROGRAMS AND IN PLACE OR
IS THIS. COMPLETELY A SEPARATE
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND AND IF THAT IS THE CASE
THEN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE
DIDN'T PROVIDE THIS FUNDING
RIGHT NOW. IN THE SPECIFIC AREA. THIS FUNDING IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF YOU
KNOW THINGS LIKE CAREER
ACADEMIES- YOU KNOW ACADEMIC
SUPPORTS. THAT WILL FOCUS ON THE
SPECIFIC AREAS IN THE TRANSITION
FROM HIGH SCHOOLS IN TO- INTER
COLLEGE- ULTIMATELY IT YET CAN
BUILD UPON EXISTING. PROGRAMS
AND SCHOOLS TO PULL TOGETHER-
THAT SAID ON THE DOWNSIDE OF NOT
DOING THIS YEAR'S WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A NEED FOR SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE IN MANY AREAS
WE KNOW WE'RE SEEING STAFFING
SHORTAGES. WE KNOW WE NEED TO
INCREASE COLLEGE GOING RATES TO
HELP ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE DON'T PURSUE
THIS PROPOSAL- AND DIDN'T MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE
SAME TYPES OF SUPPORTS TOWARD
MEETING THAT IN GOAL. OKAY LET
ME SEE IF I CAN THIS IN LITTLE
DIFFERENT. SO CURRENTLY WE HAVE
AND I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TO
THREE DIFFERENT SCHOOLS- IN MY
DISTRICT TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE-
THE SEVEN CHURCHES IS THE
CURRENT DEMAND THAT WE HAVE FOR
YOU- CAREERS OR THE SHORTAGE
THAT WE HAVEN'T. IN CRANE
CAREERS- IN AREAS SO FOR
INSTANCE WE HAVE THE R. P.
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
BETTER ADDRESSING THIS TRYING TO
BRING IN SKILLED- PERSONNEL TO
COME AND TEACH OUR STUDENTS ARE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. 'M IN
AREAS THAT YOU KNOW ARE NEEDED.
REGIONALLY WE HAVE- CAREER TECH
SCHOOLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY DOING
THE SAME THING THEY'RE- THEY'RE
COLLABORATING WITH LOCAL
CHAMBERS AND- AND LOCAL
INDUSTRIES TO SEE. WHAT IS IT
WHAT WHAT IN THE WORK FORCE TO
THE NEED TO. WHAT AREAS IN
WORKFORCE OF THE NEED TO SO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT
NOW IS WHAT IS CURRENTLY
HAPPENING- IN AREAS SUCH AS
MINE. SO I'M JUST GONNA HERE IS
THIS FUNDING GOING TO HELP THOSE
PROGRAMS ALWAYS IS INTENDED TO.
CREATE ANOTHER- OTHER VENUES-
FIND OTHER PROGRAMS. NEW PROGRAM
. MISTER THAT MAKE SENSE BUT
WE'LL SEE ARE YOU GOING TO SEND
THEM. SURE IT IT IN FIRST TWO
THE FOLK IS ON. OF THE THAT ARE
. AND EDUCATION POGRAM THAT ARE
WE WOULD CONSIDER CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WHICH IS A LOT OF WHAT THE FOCUS
IS ON YOU KNOW THROUGH CURRENT
PROGRAMS TO WORKERS WERE
ATTEMPTING TO FOCUS ON NEW AREAS
WERE ATTEMPTING TO FOCUS ON
AREAS THAT OFTEN REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT. A COLLEGE EDUCATION
OR HAVE DIFFERENT PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE EDUCATION I'M SO
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT THAT'S
ARE FOCUSED ON WE DON'T THINK
THE CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE
NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON THOSE
PARTICULAR HERE LET ME ASK A
FOLLOW UP. YOU MIGHT NEED TO
HEAR. AND THE FOLLOW UP IS-
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT THE SENATOR
WAS TRYING TO ASK IS THIS IS AN
OVERLAY TO OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT DOESN'T DUPLICATE THEM AND
ADDS TO THEM. AND THE BASIC
UNDERLYING PROGRAM AS IT EXISTS
NOW WILL CONTINUE AND IF THIS
WAS APPROVED THIS WOULD BE AN
OVERLAY THAT WOULD ADD. TO IT.
IS THAT CORRECT. YEAH THAT WOULD
BE GREAT OKAY. IT AND THE
SENATOR MAY HAVE WANTED TO KNOW
OF THE JUSTIFICATION FOR HAVING
THE OVERLAY BUT I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT OF HER QUESTIONS
WERE DRIVING ACTED AND NOW SINCE
I PUT ALL THESE WORDS IN THE
SENATOR SMITH LET ME RECOGNIZE
TO SENATOR. THE DECLARED I
RESPECT YOU ALWAYS ACTUALLY CAN
BE MADE AS LITTLE MORE TICKET
LET ALONE ELOQUENTLY AND I DO SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
ASSISTANCE- ONE LAST QUICK. WELL
MORE OF A COMMENT I GUESS
BECAUSE- HE HAD A QUESTION FOR
ME BUT MORE OF A COMMENT- I WANT
TO BEG TO DIFFER. BECAUSE I- I
ASSURE YOU THAT THE PROGRAMS IN
THE SCHOOLS THAT I'M CURRENTLY
VISITING- IN MY DISTRICT IN MY
REGION. ARE SPECIFICALLY-
ADDRESSING OR ENQUIRING AS TO
THE CURRENT NEED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- THEY'RE CURRENTLY
AT IN WORKING COLLABORATION WITH
LOCAL INDUSTRIES TO FIND OUT
WHAT EXACTLY IT IS THAT IS
NEEDED IN OUR REGION TO BE ABLE
TO TRAIN THAT SPECIFIC
WORKFORCE. IN THAT AREA SO I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IT'S CURRENTLY
BEING DONE IN MY REGION AND I'M
ACTUALLY KIND OF EXCITED NOT TO
HEAR THAT- THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY BEING VERY PROACTIVE
THAT WE ARE. YOU KNOW TRYING TO
PURSUE THIS YEAR LEGISLATIVELY
FACT WE HAVE SCHOOLS ALREADY IN
PLACE THAT ARE CURRENTLY DOING
THAT AND I. I COMMEND THEM FOR
THOSE EFFORTS FOR TAKING THE
INITIATIVE AND- IN BEING
PROACTIVE ON THAT FRONT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I THINK
THAT COMPLETES- ISSUE ONE A IN
FRONT OF A CLEARLY WELL CALF AND
THEY DID. COMMITTEE AND SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE ONE B. DUAL ENROLLMENT
ALSO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WITH THE SAME THREE
PANELISTS THAT WE HAD ON THE
FIRST ISSUE WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I CAN
MORNING AGAIN LIST MY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. RECENT RESEARCH FOR
ME SHE GAVE US A THIS WILL HOUSE
CENTER FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEADERSHIP AND SEARCH AND THE
CASE ROUGHLY EIGHTY PERCENT. OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
POPULATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN DISSIPATED AND AT LEAST
ONE DORM ROOM OF COURSE
OPPORTUNITY WHILE IN HIGH
SCHOOL. ACCORDING TO THE CENTER
AND NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
BENEFITS FOR PARTICIPANTS I DO
ONE MOMENT RELATIVE TO NON
PARTICIPANTS. INCLUDING DONNELLY
IS HAVING HIGHER RATES OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION AND COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT CREDIT ACCUMULATION.
PERSISTENCE AND COMPLETION- FOR
EXAMPLE A RECENT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALICE'S INDICATED THAT 44% EVERY
SINGLE MOMENT STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN. TWO YEAR COLLEGES COMPARED
236% OF ALL HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES AND 3637% ENROLLED IN
FOUR YEAR COLLEGES COMPARED 226%
OF ALL GRADUATES. DESPITE THE
NUMBER STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
DUAL ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES
INCREASING IN RECENT YEARS THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE'S
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
PARTICIPATION IN DAHLE ROMAN
OPPORTUNITIES AND OUTCOMES
VARIES ACROSS RACIAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS AND SOME DAHLE ROMAN
OPPORTUNITIES DO NOT LEAD TO
COLLEGE CREDIT. IN ORDER TO
EXPAND ACCESS AND PARTICIPATION
IN ONE MOMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
INCENTIVIZE THE OFFERING A BILL
ROMAN OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
ALSO COUPLED WITH STUDENT
ADVISING AND SUPPORT SERVICES.
THE FUNDS WILL BE USED TO AWARD
THREE TYPES OF COMPETITIVE
GRANTS LEN. MONEY CAN BE USED TO
ONE COUPLE WERE BEST STUDENT
ADVISING AND SUCCESS SUPPORTS
WITH AVAILABLE DAHLE MOMENT IN
ACCELERATED COLLEGE CREDIT
OPPORTUNITIES. TO PLAN FOR AND
STARTUP- A MIDDLE AND AN EARLY
COLLEGE HIGH SCHOOL LOCATED ON
THE CAMPUS OF AN- EARLY AGE. AND
THREE ESTABLISH A COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAY AGREEMENT.
AND FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WILL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE MORNING AGAIN MICHAEL OF
THAT AS WITH THE L. A. O. WE
HAVE A- OUR PRIMARY CONCERN WITH
THE PROPOSAL IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
IDENTIFIED WHAT PROBLEMS
CURRENTLY EXIST FOR GLUING ROMAN
IN PARTICULAR THE ADMINISTRATION
DOES NOT SPECIFY WILL BEAR YEARS
ELLIE EIGHT CURRENTLY FACE IN
IMPLEMENTING TO ON THE PROGRAMS
AND HOW IT IS NOT FUNDING MIGHT
REMOVE THESE BARRIERS. FOR
EXAMPLE MOST OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR GOING HOME AND IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE THE LEVEL
OF STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH
AS TUTORING. IF THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT SPECIFY
HOW CURRENT FUNDING. IS USED TO
SUPPORT- STUDENTS IS ADEQUATE AT
HIGH SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. GIVEN THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CURRENTLY ARE RECEIVING
FUNDING FROM THE STATE FAR IN
EXCESS OF THEIR MOMENT LEVELS.
WE QUESTION WHETHER STUDENTS
INCLUDING NEWLY ENROLLED
STUDENTS. HAVE A AN ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO TUTORS COUNSELORS AND
OTHER SUPPORT STAFF. IN THE CASE
OF ONE DOOMBEN TYPE OF PROGRAM
CALLED CAREER AND- SORRY
CREATING COLLEGE ACCESS PATHWAYS
PROGRAM WHICH I'LL REFER TO AS
HE CAPPED. IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
THE FUNDING BARRIERS EXIST AT
ALL. OF THAT IS GENERAL INTEREST
PROGRAMS HAS INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY IN RECENT YEARS TO
GET FROM WOMEN HAS GROWN EVEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC GOING
AGAINST THE OVERALL TREND. OF
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MORE RATHER
THAN POSING VERY SEEK FUNDING
POLICIES CAN WORK TO BENEFIT OF
SCHOOL AND COLLEGES IS
PARTICULARLY THE CASE. WITH
STUDENTS SIX HE KEPT HORSES IN
PLACE OF THE REGULAR HIGH SCHOOL
COURSEWORK. IN SUCH CASES
SCHOOLS CAN RECEIVE ATTENDANCE
BASED FUNDING EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY ONLY BE. PROVIDING THREE
HOURS OF INSTRUCTION RATHER THAN
THE STANDARD SIX HOURS OF
INSTRUCTION PER DAY. AS FAR AS
WITH THE GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS
PROPOSAL WE HAVE CONCERNS THIS
PROPOSAL DOES LITTLE LITTLE TO
TARGET FUNDING TO STUDENTS THAT
WOULD BENEFIT MOST FROM THE
PROGRAM- AS WITH THAT PROGRAM IF
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTS A DORM A
PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WAYS TO
TARGET FUNDING TO SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS WITH HIGHEST NEED. A
COMPOSER COMMENTS THANK YOU. AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THE MORNING BE
CALLOUS AGAIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- THE CITY AGREES WITH
THIS- MY EYES PROPOSAL. AND ALSO
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
NORMAL PROGRAMS MY DIVISION-
SUPPORTS EARLY COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL AND MIDDLE COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER NUMERIC
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND YOUR
MOMENT PROGRAMS- BETWEEN
SECONDARIES ARE SECONDARY
SCHOOLS AND POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TEST FUNDING
HAPPENS REFLECTIONS RIPPER SHAPE
THAT BONE. I'M JUST GONNA ASK
ONE QUESTION ON THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW WILL REVISIT ALL OF THESE
UNDER INFORMATIONAL ITEM T. BUT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST THEY TALKED
ABOUT. THE HOTSPOT THEY'RE NOT
BEING CLARITY ON HOW THIS WILL
ADDRESS THE BARRIERS THAT ARE
DONE FIVE DID THEY ALSO MENTION
TUTORING COULD YOU RESPOND. TO
THE CONCERNS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. SURE CHRIS FERGUSON
FINANCE I THINK FROM OUR PER. WE
NOTE THAT THAT PART OF THE ISSUE
IS JUST. AND UNDER- ENROLLMENT.
IN THE POTENTIAL NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT COULD BE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE KNOW THAT THE
DATA CLEARLY DISPLAYS. THAT
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE IN DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GO TO COLLEGE- SO
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW THAT'S SORT
OF OUR FOCUS AND THE PROBLEM
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS IS
MEDIAN. TAKE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE PARTICIPATING
IN DUAL ENROLLMENTCULTURE AND- THAT ALSO HAS THE
BENEFIT OF YOU KNOW REDUCING
TIME 2 DEGREES USING STUDENTS
COST TO OBTAIN A COLLEGE DEGREE-
BY ENABLING THEM TO EARN COLLEGE
CREDITS WHILE THERE AND IN HIGH
SCHOOL. I THINK THAT THAT'S OUR
PRIMARY FOCUS K. AND S. I WOULD
JUST MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS
HOME. I THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE
TIMES WHERE. EVERYBODY AGREES ON
THE GOAL. THIS IS DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS THE GOAL BUT THEY'RE
STILL A LITTLE BIT OF A LACK OF
CLARITY OF HOW THIS WILL
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE PROBLEM SO
I JUST HOPE OVER THE TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY- THAT THAT
ISSUE IS CONSIDERED OUR ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON THIS. CENTER ROADSHOW. SO S.
WHO'S- OF A TWENTY TWO AND A
TWENTY YEAR OLD AND THEY WENT
THROUGH- THEIR HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEY DID PROVIDE DUAL ENROLLMENT
ON THERE. MY CHILDREN TOO AB
CLASSES. AND ONE OF MY KIDS
ACTUALLY WENT IN WITH ENOUGH
CREDITS WITH AID TO BE A JUNIOR
. BUT THE QUESTION I'M I'M
TRYING TO SEE WHAT THE BARRIERS
RIGHT NOW TO DUAL ENROLLMENT
BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY WE DID NOT CHOOSE TO DO THAT
AND I WASN'T SURE WHETHER OR
NOT. IT WAS DUE TO THE FACT THAT
. FEEDING AND WITH THE BOTH A
HIGH SCHOOL. DIPLOMA ALONG WITH
A CERTIFICATE OR- DID IT
EFFECTIVE- THEIR GPA WHAT WHAT.
SORT OF. OBSTACLES YOU SEE TO
HAVING- ARE GOING THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE FOR HIGH SCHOOL
SAID I HAVE NOT ENTERED INTO
AGREEMENTS TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THOSE TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGH SCHOOLS THAT CURRENTLY HAVE
THE PROGRAM. SURE RIGHT I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE THE TYPE OF REQUISITE
SUPPORT SERVICES TO ALWAYS BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES OF COURSE OUR OUR FOCUS
IS. THEN YOU KNOW COURSES THAT I
YOU KNOW OFFER THAT COLLEGE
CREDIT WE KNOW THE DATA. FROM
RECENT REPORTS FROM THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE INDICATING THAT MANY OF THE
DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TODAY ARE ACTUALLY
FOCUSED ON REMEDIAL. COURSEWORK
THE DOES NOT COUNT FOR COLLEGE
CREDIT- SHOULD CERTAINLY I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO CHIU FOCUSED ON
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES THAT ISSUE
COLLEGE LEVEL UNITS THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE GREEN UP
PROGRAM SO YOU KNOW UPON.
ENTERING A COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
SO THAT I IT HELPS WITH TIME
2 DEGREES FORWARD WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT A COUPLE OF THE BARRIERS
THAT ADDS A HIGH SCHOOLS ONE OF
THE BARRIERS THAT WE PERTAINING
TO LEAVE FROM SCHOOLS. IS THAT
THE STAFFING IF YOU WERE A
DEVELOP THE AGREEMENTS TO
ENTRENCH. I WOULD THIRD LOOK
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. TO PULL
TOGETHER THE DIP COURSE ON AND-
THE THAT THERE IS. A NEED
SUPPORT FOR THEM TO HAVE A
SUPPORT PERSON THE POLL THAT.
TOGETHER INITIALLY- AND THEN THE
SECONDARY PIECE THAT WE PUT
FORWARD WHICH IS YOU KNOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS. IN TAKING THOSE
COURSES FOR THEIR SUCCESSFUL-
WHEN THEY TAKE THAT COURSE THE
FIRST TIME SO WE JUST NEED THE
SUPPORT SERVICES. AS A NECESSARY
COMPONENT AND IN SUPPORTING ALL
TYPES OF STUDENTS IN THESE
COURSES- AND CERTAINLY- THE DATA
DOES SUGGEST AT THE MOMENT THAT.
THERE MAY BE SOME EQUITY ISSUES
AND WHO IS ACCESSING CURRENT-
DUAL ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES-
WITH THE ODD UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS. I'M NOT ALWAYS BEING
HAVE THE SAME- HAVING THE SAME
TYPE OF ACCESS TO THESE COURSES.
I'M SO CERTAINLY WE'RE TRYING TO
INCENT ABROAD USE AND ACCESS OF
THESE COURSES STATEWIDE- WE KNOW
IT VARIES DEPENDING ON WHAT AREA
OF THE STATE YOU YOU ARE LOCATED
IN AND WE KNOW THAT NOT EVERY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. HAVE
YOU. CARRERA ACCESS PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE- WE. KNOW
MANY NEW BUT NOT OLD. I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO TRYING
TO. THE STUDENTS THAT WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS I TRULY
TRULY APPRECIATE THE MERIT
BEHIND THAT. AND THEN ONE LAST
QUESTION- THE CURIOUS BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW WHY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
WILL NEED ON GOING- OUR- SUPPORT
. SURE I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IT GETS THE BALANCE
OF AVAILABLE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT RESOURCES- THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY SO IT IT DEPENDS
ON THE SPECIFIC FISCAL YEAR- IT
JUST DEPENDS ON. WHETHER YOU
KNOW THE WHICH ULTIMATELY LEADS
TO WHETHER THOSE FUNDS ARE ONE
TIME OR ONGOING YOU KNOW-
THERE'S ROUGHLY A BALANCE THAT
SPLIT BETWEEN AVAILABLE ONGOING
RESOURCES AVAILABLE ONE TIME
RESOURCES WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
MAXIMIZE. THE ONE TIME RESOURCES
WE HAVE OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD- UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT
IN A POSITION WHERE WE HAVE- YOU
KNOW THE LEVEL OF- ONGOING
RESOURCES THAT WOULD ALLOW
ONGOING COMMITMENT IN THIS AREA
. SERVICE MEAN THAT THIS
PARTICULAR FUNDING YOU WILL
ACTUALLY SET IT ASIDE TO ASSURE
THAT IT ACTUALLY. IS AVAILABLE
FOR THE FOLLOWING COUPLE WHAT IS
IT FIVE YEARS THREE YEARS OR
FIVE YEARS. ON THIS PARTICULAR
NIGHT THAT WE- SO WE I'M SORRY
BECAUSE BECAUSE I GUESS WITH THE
OTHER PROBLEMS AS WELL WHEN YOU
HAVE PROGRAMS IN FUNDING
AVAILABLE. THROUGH A PERIOD OF
TIME. DOES THAT MEAN THAT YOU
SPECIFICALLY PUT THAT THOSE
FINDINGS. TO THE SIDE AND SAY
OKAY THIS WILL BE A SPREAD OVER
THREE FIVE YEARS- OR DO YOU MAKE
THAT COMMITMENT HERE BUT IF THE
FUNDING IS NOT. ONE THREE OR
FIVE YEARS. THEY DON'T RECEIVE
IT HOW DOES THAT WORK. SHE WHAT
THE WAS TRY THE GREEN ISN'T TO
COVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD. WITH
THE EXPECTATION THAT OUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WOULD BE
SPENDING AROUND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ON THE
STREET SUPPORT SERVICES SITE- IN
TERMS OF ENTERING INTO
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENTS AND
DEVELOPING SOME OF THE COURSE
WORK REVIEW THAT. AS A MORE
LIMITED TERM ACTIVITY- AND THAT
PARTICULAR COMPONENT IS ONLY FOR
ONE YEAR BUT THE PROGRAM FOR AT
LARGE AND IS EXPECTED TO COVER A
MULTI YEAR PERIOD AND GRANTEES
ARE EXPECTED TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES. OVER THAT MULTI YEAR
PERIOD. FOR JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION YOU WILL SET THIS
MONEY ASIDE. AND BE ASSURED THAT
IT WILL BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THAT PERIOD OF TIME THAT IT'S A-
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE. I'LL
NETWORK THAT'S- OKAY THANK YOU.
I KNOW IT IN A THE SENATOR MAN
HAS QUESTION BUT IF I CAN OFFER
A. B. COMMENT ON THE LAST
EXCHANGE HELLO I KNOW THIS IS
PROP NINETY EIGHT BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO US- ON MR FERGUSON WHERE
HE WAS WHEN I WAS A CABINET
SECRETARY FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
FINANCE WAS ALWAYS SAYING WE
CAN'T DO. NEW ON GOING PROGRAMS
WITH ONE TIME FUNDS AND THEN I
WAS FIGHTING AND FIGHTING AND
FIGHTING AND SO I AM AMUSED BY
THIS AND JUST REALLY WISH HE HAD
BEEN IN THE RESOURCES ASSIGNMENT
WHEN I WAS BY CABINET SECRETARY
LET ME RECOGNIZE- CENTER MAN
OKAY HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AFTER. SO ARE WE
APPRECIATE THAT PANEL AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE ONE C.
WHICH IS THE PATHWAY GRANT
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SKILLED CAREERS
IT'S WITHIN HE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SO OUR THREE
PANELISTS ARE DANIEL HANNAH WERE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
POSTING HOUSE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WITH IT NAVARETTE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND WE'LL GO
IN THAT ORDER. MISTER HAN OUR
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU CHAIR- GOOD MORNING DAN HAND
OVER TO PROBABLY FINANCE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CLOSE TWENTY
MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR A
GRANT PROGRAM THAT INCENTIVIZES
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
PREPARE STUDENTS IN GRADES NINE
TO FOURTEEN FOR THE HIGH SKILLED
FIELDS OF TECHNOLOGY. EDUCATION
AND EARLY EDUCATION. STEM AND
HEALTH CARE FEELS. THIS
INVESTMENT IS SIMILAR TO A
PREVIOUS INVESTMENT OF TEN
MILLION PROVIDED AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND THAT I'M
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE ABOUT THIS INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
THE LA. GOOD MORNING POLICY
HOUSING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AS A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
MENTIONED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. FOR THE PATHWAYS GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS FORMALLY KNOWN
IN STATUTE IS THE CALIFORNIA
STEM WHICH IS SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH. PATHWAYS
GRANT PROGRAMS. SO JUST TO MAKE
THAT CONNECTION TO THE PROPOSAL.
EXEMPT COMMITTEE JUST HEARD THE
PATHWAYS GRANT PROGRAM IS REALLY
A UNIQUE TYPE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT
THE COHORT OF STUDENTS TO START
TOGETHER NINTH GRADE. THEY TAKE
A MIX OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSES AND
THEY CONTINUED. TO AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IN A TECHNOLOGY OR
SCIENCE RELATED FIELD. AND ALONG
THE WAY STUDENTS RECEIVE
INDIVIDUALIZED INSTRUCTION
SUPPORT THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
PROGRESS AT THEIR OWN PACE.
ANOTHER UNIQUE COMPONENT OF THIS
PATHWAYS GRANT MODEL IS. IN THE
INDUSTRY THREE PROVIDES INPUT ON
CURRICULUM PROVIDES MENTORSHIPS
. TO STUDENTS AND OTHER WORK
BASED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS INTERNSHIPS AND INDUSTRY
AGREES- THE INDUSTRY PARTNERS
COMMIT TO GIVING FIRST PRIORITY
TO HIRING PROGRAM GRADUATES ONCE
THEY FINISH THE PROGRAM. THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ASKED TO
FIND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS MORE
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. TO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE A MORE INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU- WERECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ASKING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PROVIDE A
STATUS UPDATE. ON THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING FUNDED
WITH THOSE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN DOLLARS A LEGISLATURE
COULD ASK THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. FOR INFORMATION SUCH AS
HOW MANY STUDENTS INITIALLY
STARTED THE PROGRAMS. HOW MANY
ARE STILL IN THESE PROGRAMS THE
DEMOCRATS OF THOSE. AND WHAT
KIND OF PROGRESS THERE MAKE. IT
TOWARD THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
AND COLLEGE CREDITS ARE ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS COMPILED
SOME INITIAL DATA FROM THE SIX
GRANTEES WITH THAT EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN MONEY. THE LEGISLATURE
MAY ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT
HOW THEY CAME UP WITH THE AMOUNT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. ANY
INDICATIONS THEY HAVE FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN INDUSTRY. AND THAT
THERE IS THAT THE DEMANDS KNOW
FOR ADDITIONAL GRANTS I DON'T
KNOW LEGISLATURE CAN USE ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION TO WEIGH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AGAINST.
OTHER TOP PRIORITIES THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
WILL MOVE TO THE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LAYERED IN
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE MANY MISSILES THAT
NEVER AT THE CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGES CALIFORNIA MICHAEL JUST
TAKE PRIDE IN ROBUST DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AND CREATING
EARLY PATHWAYS. TO COLLEGE TODAY
BURSTING POPULATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA SAMPATH PLEASE GRANT
PROGRAM SUPPORTS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AS WE SHARED BY THE
ALLEY- IN SIX COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS BUT THE GOAL OF
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR. JOBS IN
TECH D. OF CARE AGRICULTURE AND
MANUFACTURING THE PROGRAM
INCLUDES THE KEY TENETS OF THE
NATIONAL PATHWAYS IN TECHNOLOGY
MODEL KNOWN AS P. TECH.
INCLUDING A COST FREE STEM
PATHWAY FOR STUDENTS IN GRADES
NINE THROUGH FOURTEEN TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WORKPLACE
LEARNING THEIR MENTORSHIP AND
INTERNSHIPS. THE GRANTS- FORWARD
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH AN RF PEAS
ARE AT REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL
POLITIES. THANKS VERY GOOD VERY
GOOD IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING
LEADERSHIP. WE ARE GRATEFUL.
SEVEN TWO PER AT SIX CALL THIS.
EACH PARTNERING WITH ONE TO TWO
HIGH SCHOOLS AND INDUSTRY
PARTNERS THE GRANT TERM IS FOUR
YEARS RUNNING FROM JUNE FIRST OF
TWENTY NINETEEN TO DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE MODEL COMBINES PUBLIC
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS WITH
INDUSTRY ARE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- BY CONTRAST TO THE
NATIONAL MODEL ACTUALLY OFFER AN
ASSOCIATE'S. DEGREE IN SCIENCE
FOR TRANSFER IN CERTIFICATES
WHEREAS MOST- OTHER PROGRAMS OUT
PROVIDE AN APPLIED ASSOCIATES WE
DO INTEGRATE A TRANSFER
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THESE
MODELS THE CURRENT PROGRAMS
SERVING OVER SIX HUNDRED
STUDENTS. AND WITH THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING STEM PATHWAYS TO MORE
CURRENT- POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TRADITIONALLY
LEFT OUT. 64% DIVIDENDS- THAT
ARE BEING SERVED ARE FEMALE AND
REPRESENTS A WIDE DIVERSITY
INCLUDING GREATER REPRESENTATION
OF BLACK AND LATINO STUDENTS.
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE COMPARISON
MOMENT BUT LET ME ASK THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- OF. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS DID POINT OUT THAT-
REPORT ON THE INITIAL PROGRAM
WAS DOING TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS
THERE ANY INTENT. TO REPORT ON
THAT BEFORE WE HAVE TO MAY
REVISE SO WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
THAT REPORT HERE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- WE ACTUALLY
COLLECT I JUST STATUS UPDATES
FROM EACH OF THE PROGRAM'S WILD
IT AS A SHARED- WE DON'T HAVE A
REPORT DUE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WE DO HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY
STATUS. THAT AND GIVEN THIS
PROPOSAL WE WILL MAKE AVAILABLE
TO MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADVANCE OF ME REVISED TO HELP
INFORM YOUR DECISIONS ON THAT IS
WHERE SOME OF OUR ENROLLMENT
DATA COMES LET ME KNOW THAT-
NUMBER STUDENTS WERE SERVING-
AND THE RACE AND ETHNICITY
COMPOSITION OF THE STATE. GROUPS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES.
CENTER GROVE TROUBLED YOU COULD
MAYBE ASK HIM AND THE NEXT THING
IF YOU'RE STILL SO LET'S MOVE TO
ISSUE ONE D. WHICH IS COMPARING
THE GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS GRANT
PROGRAM DUAL ENROLLMENT. AND
PATHWAY GRANT PROGRAM FOR HIGH
SKILLED CAREER SEN WE HAVE A
CHART. BOSTON ARE GENDER THAT
COMPARES TO THREE AND WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT EACH ONE. I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S- ANYONE MAYBE
I'LL JUST ASK. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT WISHES TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THE OVERVIEW OF
COMPARING THREE. I DON'T KNOW IF
MISTER STATE HOUSING OR MISTER
OFFERS HAS ANY COMMENTS OR I SEE
MR CABRAL RISING- IN THE-
DIGITAL ETHER HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY SOMETHING MR CABRAL IF A
GOOD MORNING- MISTER MEMBERS
UNDER CABRAL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS IS
THAT LOOK THROUGH I THINK WHEN
YOU WALK THROUGH THE DETAILS OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND I THINK- YOU
KNOW ASKING THE SIDE BY SIDE YOU
CAN SEE THE AREAS WHERE THEIR
SIMILARITIES THEY ALL ARE TRYING
TO GET TO THE SORT OF SAME LONG
TERM. GOAL IN A LOT OF WAYS OF
INCREASING- THE EDUCATION AND
SKILLS THAT THAT STUDENTS HAVE
SO THEY CAN FIND OCCURS IN THE
WORKFORCE- BUT THEY DO HAVE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT- ELEMENTS FOR
DOUBLE THE COVERAGE OF
PARTICULAR- HAS A GREATER FOCUS
ON- ALIGNING WITH EIGHT ZERO
COMMENTS THURMOND THAT THEIR
PROPERTIES ARE GETTING A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE I THINK I WOULD JUST
RE READING SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
ARE THAT YOU KNOW WITH WITH ALL
THESE LAYERS OF PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO THE EXISTING ONGOING
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST- BUT
CRITICAL EDUCATION. BUT THIS IS
A LOT OF- WE'RE NOW I'M IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES
WITH SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BE A THREAT
TO BE BURDENSOME I'M I THINK
OTHER THING I WOULD I WOULD NOTE
THAT ON ON THIS ISSUE OF AND TRY
TO MAKE SURE THE THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE. HELPING TO IMPROVE
PARTICULARLY FOR- STUDENTS WHO
HAVE OUR WEATHER STARTS HAD A
ROUTE WORST COLLEGE AGREED
OUTCOMES I MEAN THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS PART OF THE GOAL OF THE
BOB DOLE ENROLLMENT OTHERS AND
SOME OF THE RECENT REPORTS THERE
WAS- PARENTS THAT THE BENEFIT OF
DOING THAT ARE NOT SPREAD EVENLY
THROUGHOUT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
WE CAN GIVE YOU DO OF COURSE ANY
OF THESE OPTIONS WE THINK
THERE'S ROOM FOR MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS TO THESE PROPOSALS.
ARE NOT NOTHING IN ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE MIND ADDRESSES ANY
OF THOSE ISSUES ARE BETTER THE
PRIORITIZATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS VERY MINIMAL SO IF THAT'S IF
YOU'RE ABOVE AVERAGE DROPOUT
RATE YOU WOULD GET YOU COULD.
ALSO GET FUNDING. THERE NO
REQUIRED THEN EXAMPLE ON ONCE.
OR OF FUNDING FOR THE THEY
PRIOR. THESE AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
THAT I WOULD. HAVE LOWER
OUTCOMES ABOUT YOUR CALL TEAM
AND- WE THINK THOSE ARE. .ORG BE
A AN AREA IF YOU DO. ANY OF-
THERE'S OFTEN. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT. BUT A SEE ANY OTHER
HANG. FROM THE STATE. LEVEL IN
THE SO I WOULD. SUGGEST THAT.
THE THOSE WERE. AND WE HAVE FOR
MONTHS BEFORE THE MAY REVISE OR
THREE AND THAT. THAT WE CAN SOME
FROM LET ME ASK MY CALL. IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS POINT SUNDARA CHOLA BOOK.
I'M I NOTICED THAT M. WE ONLY
HAD SIX COMMUNITY. I'M HOPING.
MAYBE I'M NOT REALLY THE
PREVIOUS ONE AND I APOLOGIZE BUT
I'M JUST GONNA CURIOUS- IT MIGHT
BE RELATED TO THIS ONE BUT IT
MADE TO THE PREVIOUS ONE AS WELL
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SIX COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT APPLY TO THE TO
THE- PROPERTY PROGRAM. AND WE
HAVE I KNOW THEY WERE ORDERED TO
SEVEN BUT ONLY SIX QUALIFIED. DO
WE HAVE WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE WE ONLY HAVE
SEVEN APPLICANTS- IN ONLY SIX
THAT ACTUALLY QUALIFY THEY WERE
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING THESE
THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE IT SEEMS
COMPLETELY. UNUTILIZED EVER
TRYING TO MAKE ARE. GREATER
IMPACT RESISTANCE MORE OF A
LIMITED- GROUP OF COLLEGES WERE
WERE HELPING SO THAT WE'RE GOING
TO STUDY IN THE PROCESS TO SEE
IF IT WORKS. MANY TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION GOOD MORNING CENTER
CHAU BLOKE. AT THE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A CROSSER- COLLEGES USUALLY
FIFTY FIFTY EIGHT OF OUR
DISTRICTS HOW DO ON ROLE MEANT
PROGRAMS. SINCE THESE ARE ONE
TIME DOLLARS A TEN MILLION ON
THE OF WAR IT WAS LIMITED FUNDS
ONLY A SEVEN. PARTNERSHIPS COULD
BE FUNDED AND ESTABLISHED THEY
ALSO HAVE TO STRETCH THOSE
RESOURCES OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD THIS REALLY HAS TO DO
MORE WITH THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT WERE AVAILABLE.
RATHER THAN- INTEREST IN THESE
TYPES OF PARTNERSHIPS
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS STAND.
BECAUSE THERE IS AN INDUSTRY
PARTNER COMPONENT. IT IS FAR
MORE INVOLVED THAN OTHER AND
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS- BUT WE
HAVE SEEN SOME BENEFITS
PARTICULARLY. FOR DIVERSE
STUDENT GROUPS. SO IS THAT TO
UNDERSTAND ASIDE FROM THE ONE
TIME FUNDING BEING AVAILABLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT TO SAY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE MORE INTEREST- IN
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM ACROSS
THE STATE IN THE REST OF OUR
COMMITTEE CALL. WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE MAY BE MORE INTEREST AND
WE HAVE T GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS THAT
WE RECEIVED- BUT WE ALSO- DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO FIND
MORE PROGRAMS. SO WE CAN GO BACK
AND LOOK- WHEN THE PROVIDE THAT
STATUS UPDATE LET YOU KNOW HOW
MANY TOTAL APPLICANTS WE
RECEIVED- AND WHAT THE INTEREST
LOOKS LIKE ACROSS THE STATE. THE
FIRST NEW YORK ON. IN THIS
SPACE- HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT I USE
THIS INFORMATION AND MOVING
FORWARD AS- I'M SORT OF A MODEL
PROGRAM A PILOT PROGRAM TO SEE
HOW IT ACTUALLY- MANIFESTS
ITSELF IN. ITS COLD. LATER ON
AND THEN PERHAPS IN- WHAT IS THE
TWO THOUSAND AND. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX WE ASSESS WHETHER OR
NOT IT IS SOMETHING THAT AS A
LEGISLATURE. A GIVEN MAYBE THAT
WE HAVE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE FROM
THE THAT WE COULD PROBABLY
EXPAND A LITTLE FURTHER ACROSS
THE STATE. YES THE REPORTING
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WILL LET US KNOW HOW
THE SCHOOL BOARD OF STUDENTS.
DID WEATHER AND YOU KNOW THEY
WERE CONNECTED TO PROGRAMS OUR
COMPLETION RATES AND OTHER HE
DATA POINTS- SO THAT WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT MARKER. OUT WE CAN
ALSO WE CAN PROVIDE A STATUS
UPDATE AND SHOW YOU WHERE- HOW
THE PROGRAMS ARE PERFORMING NOW.
AND HOW MANY ARE BEING SERVED IN
TRANSITIONING IF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL BUT IT IS IT IS- VERY
SPECIFIC TYPE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAM THAT THAT CAN BE LOOKED
AT WITH THE KEY FOCUS ON. IMPACT
MAYES. FOR A LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE REPORT ON THE STATUS
UPDATE AND HOPEFULLY INCLUDING
SOME OF THE DATA ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STUDENTS IN
THE PROGRAMS WITH. THANK YOU BYE
CENTER MEANT- YES IT IS NEVER I
WOULD LOVE TO I'M PROBABLY
PRONOUNCING YOUR NAME
INCORRECTLY BUT- IS NEVER AT-
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I AM DOING
THAT- I GUESS I'M CURIOUS GOING
BACK TO ISSUE ONE A AND I DON'T
BELIEVE YOU'RE ON THAT PANEL
BUT- YEAH I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
HAD ANY THOUGHTS ON THE
ADMINISTER ABILITY OF. WHAT THE
GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS PROGRAM IS
PROPOSING- YOU KNOW IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE IS S. IT
BACK BY THE DATA THAT YOU YOU
BACK BY THE DEMAND I MEAN IT'S A
TO MY EARLIER POINT AND-
FOLLOWING THE ISSUE ANY PANEL-
YOU KNOW I DID RAISE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT
DEPARTMENT FINANCING TO DEVELOP
THIS WITHOUT CONSULTING WITH YOU
ALSO I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
YOUR REACTIONS TO THIS IN IT. I
SEE SEE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE HAD ANY- YOU KNOW
A CHANCE TO PROCESS THIS AND
WHAT IT MIGHT MEAN FOR YOU.
MORNINGS AND US SENATOR MAN. YES
YOU PRINTING CORRECTLY THANK
YOU. OUT KEY POINTS THAT ALL
HIGHLIGHT ONE READ WE DO SEE
GREAT VALUE IN DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAMS AND CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. THAT BEING SAID WE
HAVEN'T. HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY GAUGE- AND DISCUSSED WITH
BROADER ONCOLOGY GROUPS AND-
WHETHER- THEIR IDEAS AND
CONCEPTS FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE GOLDEN STATE'S PATHWAYS
PROGRAM- I DO SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN GAUGING.
AND LEARNING MORE AND HOW- WE
CAN BE SUPPORTIVE. OR ANY
FEEDBACK FROM. OUR COLLEGES AND
DISTRICTS. SO IF I TO TELL IT
THEN IS THAT WE HAVE AN DATA ON
DEMAND FOR THIS PROGRAM AT THIS
POINT. NOT AT THIS POINT- WITH.
SPECIFIC LEAD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
AROUND HOW MANY STUDENTS WOULD
BE SERVED- BUT WE- WE DO KNOW
HOW MANY STUDENTS COULD
POTENTIALLY QUALIFY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN. WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT TO EXPLORE. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I GUESS I
WOULD JUST REITERATE- I THINK MY
YEAH I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING MORE DETAILS ON ALL THREE
PROPOSALS BUT- IT STRIKES ME
THAT THE SECOND AND THIRD- WITH
A SECOND I WOULD I BELIEVE IS.
DEVELOPED IN CLOSE CONSULTATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THE THIRD
ENVISIONS ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
BE ROUTED THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- DOES MAKE
SENSE TO ME RATHER THAN. IN OF I
HAVE MY RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
FIRST CLEARLY BUT- WILL REMAIN
TO BE SEEN SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR. N. LET
ME THANK ALL THE PANELISTS ON
THE FIRST FOUR SUB ISSUES OF
ITEM ONE WE HAD A LOT OF
FEEDBACK. I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
TO TALK ABOUT IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS UP UNTIL MAY REVISED. BUT
I APPRECIATE YOUR BODY BEARING
WITH THIS BEING HERE. BECAUSE IT
WAS A GREAT DISCUSSION ON. OR
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE LITERACY
LITERACY PROPOSAL. THAT'S GOOD
STUMBLE OVER LITERACY ARM AND
OUR THREE PANELISTS ARE MACHEL
VALDIVIA OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
CHERYL COTTON. THE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT FOR INSTRUCTION
MEASUREMENT AND IT MINISTRATION.
A AT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WILL BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I CAN MORNING CHIANG
MEMBERS MUST HAVE A LEGAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUNDS FOR GRANTS TO HIGH NEED
SCHOOLS TO TRAIN AND HIRE
LITERACY COACHES AND READING
SPECIALISTS. ON THE MAJORITY OF
THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROPOSAL OR
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AS SET UP AS FORMULA
BASED GRANTS GOING OUT ON A PER
STUDENT RATE FOR EACH AT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH SIXTH GRADE STUDENT
ENROLLED IN AN ELIGIBLE SCHOOL.
SUCH THAT NO ELIGIBLE SCHOOL
RECEIVED LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS- WE WANT THESE
FUNDS TO GO TO OUR MOST HIGH
NEED STUDENTS WHICH IS WHY
ELIGIBLE SCHOOLS ARE DEFINED AS
THOSE WITH ABOUT I. EACH OF THE
- ENGLISH LEARNERS AND CAN FIND
CARE. I WITHIN THE TEACHER
THROUGH FRIENDS IN A POPULAR.
OUR MISSION ESTIMATES SHALL
ABOUT. SCHOOLS WITH QUALIFY FOR
FUNDING UNDER THIS PROPOSED. I'M
THE RIGHT THE FUNDING OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IS PROVIDED TO
CONTRACT WITH. A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY OR LGA TO
DEVELOP AND PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
LITERACY COACHES AND MEETING
SPECIALIST- WITH PRIORITY FOR
APPLICANTS WITH THEM.
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN
IMPROVING LITERACY. I'M LITERACY
COACHES CAN MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF
STRUGGLING READERS AS THEY
DEVELOP. LITERACY PROGRAMS AND
THEN TOOK TEACHERS AND IMPLEMENT
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS AND
HI IT FOR STUDENTS IN NEED- OF
TARGETED LITERATE LITERACY
SUPPORT I'M ALSO SOME STUMBLING
OVER LITERACY- AND THIS PROPOSAL
MAKES THESE COACHES AVAILABLE TO
OUR MOST HIGH NEED STUDENTS. I
CAN BECAUSE MY PRESENTATION BUT
MY COLLEAGUE AMBER ALEXANDER AND
I ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH R. O. WILL MOVE. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRS AND A LEE
WITH THE LEGACY ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE WANTED TO SHARE SENSE
AND RECOMMENDED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S. TO WRITE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME FOR
LITERACY COACHES. OVERALL WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
COOL THREE HAVE A RADIO OF
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES THROUGH
WHICH THEY CAN FIND ADDITIONAL
LITERACY COACHES MOST NOTABLY AT
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AND SEE HOW FAST. THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET EVEN PROVIDED A ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
AUGMENTATION TO LCF
CONCENTRATION GRANT TO HIRE MORE
STAFF FOR DIRECT STUDENT
SERVICES INCLUDING LITERACY
COACHES. THIS AUGMENTATION AND
IT WOULD BE TARGETED MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT WOULD RECEIVE
FUNDING UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH OF
PROVIDING RESTRICTED FUNDING FOR
CERNER DEAL EARLY LITERACY
ACTIVITIES IS NOT CONSISTENT
WITH THE REGIONAL LEGISLATIVE
INTENT ALLEYS LOCALLY FUND AND-
DETERMINE. PRIORITIES UNDER LCS
FAST. STUDY SUGGESTS THAT
LITERACY COACHING CAN'T IMPROVE
STUDENT READING TEST SCORES IF
EXPERIENCED COACHES ARE PLACED
IN THE LOWEST PERFORMING SCHOOLS
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. HOWEVER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ALIGN WITH THE RESEARCH IN THREE
KEY ASPECTS. FIRST THE PROPOSAL
IS NOT TARGETED TO THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS AS INDICATED
UNDER THE STATE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. INSTEAD
THE PROPOSAL TARGETS FINDING
BASED ON STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS.
SECOND TEMPORARY FUNDING COULD
LIMIT THE PROPOSAL'S IMPACT.
GOVERNOR'S RECALLS A WOULD ONLY
PROVIDE FUNDING OVER THREE YEARS
GIVEN THE TIME THAT IT TAKES.
HIRE TRAIN AND PLAN FOR COACHING
COACHES MAY JUST BE STARTING TO
BE EFFECTIVE AROUND THE TIME
THAT FUNDING WOULD EXPIRE.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION WOULD NOT PROHIBIT
SCHOOLS FROM USING THIS TO
SUPPLANT EXISTING FUNDING FOR
COACHES ALSO LIMITING THE IMPACT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. LAST WEEK
CURRENT STAFFING SHORTAGES COULD
RESULT IN MANY AN EXPERIENCED
COACHES BEING HIRED. WE KNOW
THAT MANY DISTRICTS ARE FACING
WIDESPREAD STAFFING SHORTAGES
INCLUDING. FOR LITERACY COACH
POSITIONS AFFECT LITERACY TO
HAVE. EXPERIENCE TEACHING
READING AND THE CLASS. STRONG
GRASP READING INSTRUCTION AND
INTO. AND EXPIRY WORKING WITH
EACH. SUCH CALL LITERACY COACHES
COULD BE DIFFICULT TO FIND IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. ALTHOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO
ADDRESS THE STAFFING LIMITATIONS
THROUGH THE PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR STATEWIDE TRAINING
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT SUCH
TRAINING QUITE EFFECTIVELY
BRIDGE THIS KNOWLEDGE GAP.
ACTUALLY SINCE THE TRAINING
MIGHT NOT BE TAILORED FOR EACH
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS
WE RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTED THE PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR LITERACY COACHES. IF THE
LEGISLATURE HOWEVER WERE
INTERESTED IN FINDING THIS
PROPOSAL WE DO OFFER SEVERAL
MODIFICATIONS. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD. BASED ON SCHOOL FINANCE
WILL PERFORMING I FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT COULD EXTEND THE
TIMELINE FROM THREE YEARS TO
FIVE YEARS AND CLARIFY THE FUNDS
ARE INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT NOT
SUPPLANT EXISTING FUNDING. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NOW WILL MOVE. ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MORE MISTER CHAIR AND
THEN OF THE CA. I AM SURE ALL
COTTON DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I'M PRESENTING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC AND
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. FIRST
I WISH I WANT TO WISH EVERYONE A
HAPPY READ ACROSS AMERICA DAY.
WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S LITERACY PROPOSAL AS
IT RELATES TO STATE
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND
STATEWIDE LITERACY AND BY
LITERACY CAMPAIGN. MOST RECENTLY
HE IS SPONSORING A BILL AB TWO
FOUR SIX FIVE THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY LITERACY AND EDUCATION
ENRICHMENT THROUGH ESTABLISHING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO ENGAGE
FAMILIES TO IMPROVE LITERACY AND
BY LITERACY OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS. REACHING LITERACY BY
THIRD GRADE HAS LONG BEEN A
COUPLE OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
A KEY BENCHMARK AND MEASURING
AND PREDICTING STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE MUST TAKE BOLD ACTION TO HELP
STUDENTS MEET THIS IMPORTANT
MILESTONE AND TO PUT THEM ON A
PATH FOR LIFELONG LEARNING AND
SUCCESS AS OPPOSED TO A PATH.
THAT INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY WILL DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL OR END UP IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE JUSTICE SYSTEM OVER 70%
OF INMATES IN CALIFORNIA I'M
SORRY IN AMERICA'S PRISONS.
CANNOT READ ABOUT FOURTH GRADE
LEVEL THAT NEEDS TO STOP THERE'S
NO BETTER TIME THAN THE PRESENT
WHEN WE ARE FOCUSED ON
TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. PUTTING
STRONG LEADERS THE ACQUISITION.
BOTH ACCESS TO MANY BOOKS AND
CAREFUL CURATION OF LIBRARIES TO
BE MOST APPROPRIATE
DEVELOPMENTAL CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC AND READABILITY
NEEDS. AND ALSO REQUIRES
EFFECTIVE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
AND SUPPORT. AS PART OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S LITERACY
CAMPAIGN THE CITY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH WHERE THE STOCKS LAST
WINTER BREAK TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH THE GIFT OF LITERACY
CAMPAIGN. ALL STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE WERE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN READING
AT HOME AT SCHOOL AND IN THE
COMMUNITY DURING THE WINTER
BREAK. THROUGH A DIGITAL
LITERACY PLATFORM. IN THE THREE
MONTHS OFTHIS PARTNERSHIP FROM
DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THROUGH FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THERE ARE
OVER FIVE MILLION BOOKS READ.
AND OVER FOR FORTY TWO POINT
SEVEN THOUSAND MINUTES OF
READING. THAT SHOWS THAT IF
STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED THE ACCESS
THEY ARE GOING TO READ. IF WE'RE
GOING TO REACH OUT I'M SORRY FOR
GOING TO REACH OUR GOAL OF
HAVING OUR STUDENTS READ BY
THIRD GRADE. SCHOOLS THEBOOKS
AND STUDENTS NEED ACCESS TO
THESE FOLKS. A SUMMARY OF THE
PROGRAM WILL BE HANDED. I WILL
BE PROVIDED TO YOU AND HAND OUT.
WE ALSO LITERACY COACH WE KNOW
FROM RESEARCH THAT ONGOING AND
STATE LITERACY COACHING IS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN ISOLATED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING OR WORKSHOPS ALONG. TO
TRULY SUSTAIN TEACHER PRACTICE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING MUST BE
ACTIVE AND COLLABORATIVE I
PROVIDE TEACHERS WITH AMPLE TIME
TO LEARN PRACTICE IMPLEMENT AND
REFLECT ON NEW STRATEGIES. FIRST
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE A STRONG
INVESTMENT PROPOSAL PLOY AND
TRAIN LITERACY COACHES AND
READING LITERACY SPECIALIST
STATEWIDE WHICH INCLUDES
DEVELOPING SCHOOL LITERACY
PROGRAMS MENTOR TEACHERS AND
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS. IN
NEED OF TARGETED LITERACY
SUPPORT. WHAT THE CURRENT
TEACHER SHORTAGE UP LIFTING NEW
AND EXISTING TEACHER LEADERS IS
IMPORTANT TO RAISING OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. RESEARCH
ALSO SHOWS THAT USE OF CULTURE
IS PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE IN
IMPROVING TEACHER PRACTICE AND
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT. ALISON
COACHING MODELS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ONE TIME WORKSHOPS CAN
BE EFFECTIVE IN TEACHERS
AWARENESS OF LITERACY PRACTICES
BUT ARE INSUFFICIENT IF THE GOAL
IS TO STAINED USE OF EVIDENCE
BASED LITERACY PACTICE. AND
ALSO COACHING PROVIDES ONGOING
JOB EMBEDDED SUPPORT FOR
TEACHERS THAT ALLOWS TEACHERS TO
PRACTICE SKILLS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM
COLLEGE. IN ADDITION TO POSITIVE
IMPACTS ON TEACHER INSTRUCTION
RICERCHE RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT
LITERACY COACHING POSITIVELY
INFLUENCES STUDENTS AND
SPECIFICALLY MULTILINGUAL
LEARNERS ACROSS THE CONTINENT
AREAS PARTICULARLY WHEN READING
LANGUAGE SKILLS VOCABULARY AND
SUBJECT AREA COMPREHENSION. OR
INTEGRATED INTO THE EFFORT. I'M
NOT ANNOUNCED OF SIXTY CAUSAL
STUDIES THAT EXAMINED THE IMPACT
OF COACHING AND TRY K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS INCLUDED LITERACY
INCLUDING LITERACY COACHING
FOUND LARGE POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
TEACHER INSTRUCTION AND SMALL
BUT STILL POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT. CONVERSELY
IMPACTS OF LITERACY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAININGS AND
WORKSHOPS WITHOUT COACHING
TYPICALLY FAIL TO CHANGE TEACHER
PRACTICE AND STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
. FURTHER AT A POINT WHEN
CLASSROOM TEACHERS ARE FEELING
THE STRAIN OF INSTRUCTION ACROSS
THE PANDEMIC THE WEIRDEST OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND ADULTS IS
HEIGHTENED. CULTURES ARE
EXPERIENCED EXPERT TEACHERS AND
LITERACY COACHING PROVIDES AN
AVENUE FOR CLASSROOM EDUCATORS
TO ENTER TEACHER LEADERSHIP AND
CONTINUE TO POSITIVELY INFLUENCE
INSTRUCTION ACROSS SCHOOL
CAMPUSES FOR DIRECT IMPACT TO
STUDENTS. THIS OPPORTUNITY
SUPPORTS THREE AREAS ONE
TEACHERS BILLS SUPPORTED
ENCOURAGED AND EMPOWERED BY
COACHING MORE LIKELY A TEACHER
WHO FEELS OF. OUR TEACHERS FEEL
SUPPORTED ENCOURAGED AND
EMPOWERED BY COACHING ARE MORE
LIKELY TO REMAIN ENGAGED A
PROFESSION IMPROVING BOTH SKILLS
AND ASPECT. NUMBER TWO TEACHERS
READY TO LEAVE THE PROFESSION
NATURES TO STANAGE OCCASION AS A
COACH HE BEEN INVALUABLE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE
ACCORDING EDUCATION AND THREE
THE MENTORSHIP ASPECT OF
COACHING BUT ALSO HELP ATTRACT
NEW TEACHERS TO THE PROFESSION
WITH THE SUPPORTED SCAFFOLD
ENTRY THAT COINCIDES WITH. THE
EFFORTS TO CREATE A MORE
EFFECTIVE TEACHER PIPELINE. OUR
STATE HAS ESTABLISHED LITERACY
COACHING NETWORKS WHICH CAN
SUPPORT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES IN THIS WORK AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ALIGNING THIS
INITIATIVE WITH OUR CURRENT
LITERACY PROJECTS. IN TERMS OF
SMALL SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS THE L.
A. L. L. A. L.'S POINT WE THINK
A CONSORTIUM COACHES COULD BE
DEVELOPED TO COVER THAT COVERS
MULTIPLE DISTRICTS OR IS EVEN
COUNTY Y. IF LEGISLATURE INDIA'S
DLF ARE INTERESTED IN THIS IDEA
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON HOW THIS COULD BE ACHIEVED.
IN CLOSING WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE INVESTMENT IN LITERACY
COACHES AS WELL AS THE COMPANION
INVESTMENT A MULTILINGUAL AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT SCHOOL AND
CLASSROOM LIBRARY. WE CANNOT
REPLY SOLELY ON PUBLIC LIBRARIES
FOR MANY OF OUR KIDS. THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE. LIBRARY HAVE JOHN
GETTING IN FROM PUBLIC LIBRARIES
. IF WE WANT EVERY. TO RE AND
ALLOW OF READING. IN THIS
CRITICAL THAT WE IN THE IN BOOKS
LIBRARY. LITERACY COACHES
MENTORS AND INTERVENTIONS FOR
STUDENTS IN NEED OF LITERACY
SUPPORT PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AS THIS PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PROVIDE HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DEAL AFTER AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON SPECIFIC POINTS
RELATED TO THESE PROPOSALS.
ALIEN THE REINA EDUCATION
STRAIGHTER IN THE EDUCATOR
EXCELLENCE AND EQUITY DIVISION
FOR CD AND I ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THIS IS A TIME FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WHAT MASS AND GROW TROUBLED. YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS. YES MONEY BIG
WITH A CAR- SO PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE IT IN A
DISTRICT THAT WE HAVE LITERACY
COACHES- IN PLACE AND I KNOW HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE- WITHIN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE SCHOOLS-
WHEN THEY'RE- WELL TRAINED AND
LITERACY- I AM A LITTLE
CONCERNED- TO. READ FROM THE
CAPITOL WEEKLY THAT- ACCORDING
TO THE ARTICLE. ON THE TWENTY
EIGHTH OF- SEE A FEBRUARY. IT
STATED THE CALIFORNIA SHOCKINGLY
HAS THE LOWEST LITERACY RATE OF
ANY STATE- AND. WITHIN THE AYE I
WANNA JUST KIND OF MENTION BUT
WE'RE DOING ALREADY AS FAR AS
THE FUNDING GOES FOR LITERACY-
AND WHY AM I TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT
THE OBSTACLES HAVE BEEN BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE ARTICLE STATED
AND THIS IS SOME FACTS THAT I'M
JUST GOING TO FACE BEFORE YOU AS
WE CONSIDER MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS PURCHASE PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL IT STATES HERE THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY. THE BUDGET
INCLUDED FIFTY MILLION TO
ESTABLISH BLOCK GRANTS TO
IMPROVE LITERACY. AND AN
ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION WAS
PROVIDED FOR LEAD COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. FOCUSED ON EFFECTIVE
LITERACY INSTRUCTION IN EARLY
GRADES. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS AND IN
ADDITION TO TEN MILLION. FOR
STATEWIDE PRO STATEWIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ON
READING INSTRUCTION
INTERVENTION. M. INTERVENTION IN
ADDITION TO STATE FUNDING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AN ON GOING
BASIS AROUND TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION. THAT IS FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING POOR STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AND TARGETED TO
STUDENTS AND POVERTY AND THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THE L. C. F. F.
FUNDING. THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
AND I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS
TO WHEN I LOOK AT ALFIE A FIVE-
WHICH TARGETS UNDUPLICATED KIDS
. I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
ARE THE OBSTACLES WHAT IS IT
THAT- BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE WE'VE
BEEN. PROVIDING A LOT OF FUNDING
FOR LITERACY WHAT OBSTACLES ARE
WE ACTUALLY FACING BUT IS NOT
ALLOWING US TO ACTUALLY HAVE
LITERACY. ON STANDARDS THAT ARE-
DIGNIFIED OF OUR KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA. AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CAN
GO AHEAD AND START AND OTHERS
CAN OUT ON- IF THERE ARE YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO MAKE
ON YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
OBSTACLES AND OF LCS FACT I
THINK- YOU KNOW REALLY THE LCF
WAS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO- ALLOCATE FUNDING
BASED ON PRIORITIES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED LOCALLY WE DO KNOW
YOU KNOW AND HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THERE ARE THERE
ARE A LOT OF THEM DIFFERENT
DYNAMICS THAT PLAY INTO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS LOCALLY THEE'S
OBVIOUSLY. NO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTSTHERE ARE
CERTAIN- YOU KNOW SECTORS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO COME FORWARD AND
ADVOCATE FOR CERTAIN PRIORITIES
AND ALL OF THOSE GAMES FACTORED
INTO INTO THOSE CONVERSATIONS SO
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COMPETING
- THAT IS ONE OF THREE. WHY I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU SEE THIS. ON
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT LITERACY
COACHES AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
OTHER MORE TARGETED INVESTMENTS
THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN THE PAST.
I'M BECAUSE WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT ALSO AFFECT YOU KNOW
SHOOTING COULD BE A FUNDING
SOURCE TO SUPPORT INVESTMENT IN
THIS AREA. BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE MULTIPLE
I'M PRIORITIES AND ASK FOR THAT
FUNDING AND IN ORDER TO. ENSURE
THAT INVESTMENT IS BEING MADE IN
THE SPACE WE DO FEEL THAT THESE
TARGETED- INVESTMENTS. ARE
NEEDED SO THAT FUNDING IS
DEDICATED TO THE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS TO IMPROVE LITERACY
OUTCOMES. DIRT COMPLETE YOUR
QUESTIONS NOT MY COMMENT THOUGH
OH GREG ABBOTT SO. AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THE OBJECTIVE BUT AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER MY PREVIOUS
STATEMENT. THIS WAS IN ADDITION
TO THAT. SO THAT THE MONEY THAT
I JUST MENTIONED IN TE AMOUNT
OF THE MONEY THAT I JUST
MENTIONED WAS IN ADDITION TO LCF
AT. THERE WERE. ALREADY A KID A
QUITE A BIT OF MONEY. TOWARDS
LITERACY- THAT IN MY OPINION
YOU' THINK THAT SOME OF THAT
WOULD BE ALLOCATED TOWARDS YOU
KNOW. LITERACY COACHES AND WE
HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
CURRENTLY HAVE THOSE IN PLACE.
SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS- LET
ME JUST STATE. WE PROVIDED A LOT
OF FUNDING FOR LITERACY- JUST IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS AGO AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN ADDITION TO
LCF AND YOU FIGURE YOU'RE
THINKING MY- DISABILITY AND THAT
. LITERACY COACHES WOULD BE
INCLUDED- AS ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS I WOULD BE AVAILABLE
ORDER DEDICATED FUNDING FOR- TO
ADDRESS LITERACY SO- AT THE.
THANK GREAT AND I AM A CENTERMAN
OR NOR I HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BUT
I'M GONNA MAKE A COMMENT. AND-
THANK SENATOR OCHO BOWED FOR
MENTIONING THE NEWS ARTICLE
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO MENTION
IT- ON LITERACY. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAVE IT. I THINK THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S COMMENTS
WERE ON POINT AND SO AS WE MOVE
TOWARD. A MAY I'D LIKE THERE TO
BE A LITTLE FOCUS. ON THIS SO
THAT WE KNOW IT'S FOCUSED TO THE
PLACES THAT MOST NEEDED AND WE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
SUPPLANT IF IT'S THERE. ARE SO
THAT IT'S CLEAR ANNA IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE AS I MOVE
AROUND AND- IN ALL OUR THE
SPRAWLING DISTRICT WITH LOTS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND ALL THE
STATE. OUR STAKEHOLDERS ARE IN
TOUCH REGULARLY ONE OF THEIR BIG
BEEFS AND IT ALWAYS AMUSES ME
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT CATEGORICAL IN
N. R. WE WENT FROM I'M NOT GONNA
GET THE NUMBER RIGHT EIGHTY
CATEGORICAL TO TWELVE ABOUT
EIGHT OR NINE YEARS AGO BUT NOW
EVERYBODY'S COMPLAINING ABOUT
TWELVE AND THIS SEEMS TO BE A DE
FACTO CATEGORICAL IN IN THE
MAKING IN THE END SO THE ONE
PEOPLE WONDER HOW WE GET TO
CATEGORICAL WE GET TO AMOUNT OF
THINGS LIKE THIS. IN AND IT'S A
A. N. I DON'T WANNA CONFUSE TWO
THINGS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S COMMENTS WERE ON THE
NEED FOR THIS AND THEY WERE ON
POINT BUT THE QUESTION IS THE
PROCESS AND THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER IT'S TARGETED FOR MEANT
TO BE EFFECTIVE WHICH I THINK
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
COMMENTS WERE DIRECTED TO SO
WELL THIS IS VERY WORDY AND IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK SHOULD BE
DONE UNDER SOME CIRCUMSTANCES
BECAUSE IT'S A NEED. THE REAL
QUESTION IS HOW IS IT DONE IS IT-DONE IN A FOCUSED WAY IS IT DONE
IN A WAY THAT TARGETS WITH THE
NEED IS GREATEST AND I THINK
THAT'S IN PART WHAT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST CONFERENCE
COMMENTS WERE AND I JUST HOPE
THEY'RE CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE
AHEAD BUT TOWARD NAY SO I THANK
EVERYBODY. FOR THAT PANEL OF
WITH BEING WITH US AND WE'LL BE
BACK TO THIS IN MAY WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
GUIDANCE INITIATIVE C. C. G. I.
N. THE PANEL CONSISTS OF ALEC
SHOPE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- AMIABLY FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
TESSA CARMEN TO ROY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDES INITIATIVE AND
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER AND. BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FIND- YOU
THIS CHAIRMAN MORNING ALEX. THAT
OF- GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
PROPOSITION I THINK EIGHT
GENERAL FUND- NINE POINT THREE
MILLION OF WHICH IS ONGOING.
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION OF WHICH
IS ONE TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDANCE INITIATIVE S.
B. C. GI. TO SCALE ITS COLLEGE
AND CAREER PLANNING SERVICES AND
TOOLS TO SERVE ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AS AUTHORIZED BY THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AT.
THESE RE THESE PROPOSAL WOULD
RESULT IN A TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FUNDING TOTAL OF TWENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR C. C. GI
AND ONGOING TOTAL. OF SIXTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION- THE NINE
POINT THREE MILLION ONGOING WILL
BE USED TO SUBSIDIZE. CURRENT
PARTICIPATING DISTRICTS AND TO
EXPAND ITS EASY G. I.'S
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY AS IT
SCALES IT'S SERVICES. INCLUDING
FOR ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
TECHNOLOGY OPERATIONS-
MAINTENANCE AND DEVELOPMENT AND
PERSONNEL- THE FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME IS FOR CCI TO
DEVELOP COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH REGIONAL
COUNTY OFFICES. OF EDUCATION TO
SUPPORT THE UTILIZATION OF CCI'S
TOOLS AND SERVICES AND SCHOOLS
AND ELEAZAR ACROSS THE STATE-
EMPOWERING REGIONAL PARTNERS. TO
LEVERAGE THEIR LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS- AND KNOWLEDGE TO
PROVIDE TARGETED SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT
LIAISON. AND USE- THAT CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS AND- I ALSO HAVE-
YEAH SACRAMENTO ROY- FROM CCA
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY.
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE LAW.
ANALYST'S OFFICE. MAYBE WE WITH
THE L. A- AGAIN. ON THE
GOVERNOR'S. I CALL REDIRECT
MANDALAY. PREVIEW ADICIONAL
DOCUMENTATION THAT SEES EACH
YEAR I WILL BE PROVIDING IN THE
SPRING AND ENSURE THAT KEY
QUESTIONS ARE ADDRESSED JUST AS
SOME BACKGROUND CCDI OFFERS AN
ONLINE PLATFORM WITH COLLEGE
CAREER AND FINANCIAL PLANNING
TOOLS. I'M FOR STUDENTS IN
GRADES SIX THROUGH TWELVE- THE
CRADLE TO CAREER WORK GROUP TO
FIND IT IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET PACKAGE RECOMMEND
EXPANDING THE CJI TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AS AN OPERATIONAL TOOL UNDER THE
CAREER. I CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM WITH TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PACKAGE OF REQUIRED
THAT THE CJI REPORT INFORMATION
BY APRIL FIRST OF EVERY YEAR
INCLUDING BUDGET CHANGER PUZZLES
DETAILS FOR PARTICIPATING L.
YATES AND IN THE TWENTY TO.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REPORT A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT EXAMINING A PLATFORM
USAGE AND WHAT LIMITS OF
EXISTING FEATURES CURRENTLY
THERE ARE ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PARTICIPATING
IN C. C. GI WITH PLANS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX NEW DISTRICTS BY FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE. FOR
REFERENCE THERE ARE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR UNIFIED
AND HIGH SCHOOL JUST STATEWIDE
MEETING THAT'S EASY I COULD
SERVE ABOUT HALF OF THE TARGETED
DISTRICTS BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. ALTHOUGH WE THINK
THE PROPOSED AUGMENTATION IS
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
INTENT THE CJI'S PLANS TO SCALE
FULLY FOR THE REMAINING
DISTRICTS ARE REMAINS UNCLEAR AS
TO WHAT THE- COST ONCE HE'S THE
GUY IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED. AS
SUCH THE CJI CAN BENEFIT FROM A
LONG TERM IMPLEMENTATION
PLANNING ON THE PROPOSED ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE THINK SUCH SUPPORT
COULD BE REASONABLE BUT A
REGIONAL APPROACH MIGHT HAVE
LIMITED IMPACT ESPECIALLY AT
LEAST. AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH THE
SELECTED C. O. E. AND THEIR
REACH AND SOME SKI QUESTIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ONCE
YOU SEE I SUBMITS ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTATION AND SPRING CAN BE
FOUND ON PAGE TWELVE OF TODAY'S
AGENDA BUT INCLUDE QUESTIONS
SUCH AS- WHAT HE SEES EACH YEAR
AS LONG TERM PLAN FOR FULLY
SCALING THE PLATFORM. WHAT ARE.
THE ONGOING COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH FULLY SCALY CCI IN OUR
UNDERLYING. A FOR. AND CAN'T SEE
PROVIDE WORK FOR ME ON WHAT WHY
DID. MIGHT WANT TO. IN C. C. AND
OTHER RELATED AREAS TO
PARTICIPATE. I COMPLETELY
TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY ANSWER. AT
THE PER TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVE THE-
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GUIDE IN THIS
. GOOD MORNING AND MEMBERS-
ACTUALLY NOT. INTENDED TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM AND HAVE INTERNET
THAT MAY ARISE IN THE DISCUSSION
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOMB. WILL
MOVE TO QUESTIONS TO MY
COLLEAGUES SEVENTY QUESTIONS NON
FROM SENATOR MAN ON FROM SENATE
ROADSHOW BOAT. LET ME- JUST ASK
. R. ONE QUESTION AND THEN THAT
IS- AS WE MOVE INTO THIS- AND I
AGREE WITH- LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
THAT THAT WE WANT TO DISHMOK
DETAILS THAT THERE WILL BE
PROVIDED IN THE SPRING. BUT PART
OF THIS IS SCALING THIS UP OVER
TIME AND WHAT IS THE COST FOR
SCALING IT UP OR WATER THE PLANS
FOR SCALING IT UP RATHER THAN
JUST STARTING IN AND MAYBE. I'D
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SURE I'LL SHOW PART OF
FINANCE- SO I MEAN I THINK. YOU
KNOW WE SEE THIS- YOU KNOW
COMING YEAR AS AND BRENT FOR
PASSING BUILDING- YOU KNOW WITH
AND C. C. GI ITSELF- I THINK
IT'S THAT. THE- YOU KNOW AYE
LAWYERS READ YOUR REPORT YOU
KNOW NOTES THAT- THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ON FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
DISTRICTS YOU KNOW FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND EXPECTS
TO ON BOARD AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED DISTRICTS- IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- TO WATCH THEIR-
DOUBTS WATCHES TOOLS BY AUGUST
OR SEPTEMBER- OF. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE- I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
WITH- CCI YOU KNOW THE- THE
CRADLE TO CREATE A DISTANCE WORK
GROUP- PUT OUT A- OPERATE TOOLS-
SORT OF ASSESSMENT- THAT
INCLUDES SCALING FOR SEASON YET-
AND THROUGH CONVERSATIONS YOU
KNOW WITH THEM I THINK WE STILL
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THIS- YOU
KNOW FUNDING LONG TERM FALL
WITHIN THAT RANGE- YOU KNOW
HOWEVER YOU HAVE WILL WILL WILL
ALSO WAY YOU KNOW. THE BUDGET IN
THE SPRING- AND YOU KNOW WILL
WILL WORK WITH THE CIA- AS FAR
AS ANY- YOU KNOW FUTURE
AUGMENTATIONS. FIRE THANK YOU- I
PUSH THAT AND YOU MADE THE
MISTAKE OF- OF RESUMING FROM A
PLACE TO DRIVE ASSEMBLY
RESOLUTION ON THE WALL BEHIND
YOU WHO SIGNED. I AM I AM I'M
DOG SITTING THIS WEEK ACTUALLY
SO THIS IS THIS IS NOT IN MY
HOUSE SO. AFTER I OULD HAVE TO
GET BACK TO. THAT SOME OF THE
BEST TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE HAD
THUS FAR. I APPRECIATE THAT SO.
COME INTO THE FIRST PERSON. THAT
HAS COPPED A DOG SITTING AS A
WITNESS SINCE WE'VE BEEN HAVING
OUR HEARING SO THAT IS REALLY
WONDERFUL. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE SIDE OF. THEN I
APPRECIATE OUR PANEL AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ISSUE FOR ITS
UNDER THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IT'S THE EDUCATOR
WORK FORCE PROPOSALS AND OUR
WITNESSES ARE MEGAN SABAH FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EMILY
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND MERRY SANDY FROM. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING GOING AND WE WILL
GO IN THAT ORDER AND BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WELCOME TO THE- COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MEGA
BLOCK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES INVESTMENTS OUT
OF FIFTY FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF SCHOOLS
TO HIRE. QUALIFIED TEACHERS AND
SUBSTITUTE. THE FUNDING BUILDS
UPON CHU POINT NINE BILLION IN
INVESTMENT FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. MANY OF
WHICH ARE MULTI YEAR TO PREPARE
TRAIN AND RECRUIT A DIVERSE
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE. I AM BRIEFLY
FROM NOTABLE INVESTMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE INCLUDES. TWENTY FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
WAIVE CERTAIN FUTURE EXAMINATION
FEES IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE TACKLE YEAR. TWELVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
EXTEND THE CURRENT WAIVER OF
BLACK CREDENTIAL AND PERMIT
CREDENTIAL FEES FOR INDIVIDUALS
ENSURING THE EDUCATED WORKFORCE
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE CENTS A YEAR. I'M
IN GENERAL FUNDING FOR ONE
POSITION ONE TIME TO SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION'S ADMINISTRATION FEE
THAT ADMITTED. AND EXAM WAIVER
PROGRAM. I ADDITIONAL THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET. HANDMADE ONE
CHEN FUND THE COMING ON
CREDENTIALING TO. A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT AN
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM. AT. FIVE FOR TWO
POSITIONS TO REESTABLISH THE
PERSONNEL MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAMS AFTER HE MET HERE AFTER. A
PROGRAM THROUGH WITH THIS LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IN
IMPROVING THEIR HIRING AND
RECRUITMENT PRACTICES. I AM ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO PROVIDE FOR EIGHT POSITIONS
AT THE COMMISSION WHICH WILL
SERVE AS SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
AND CAREER COUNSELOR. FOR
PROSPECTIVE EDUCATORS AS WELL AS
ONE POSITION WHICH WILL WORK TO
DEVELOP A MULTI FACETED WEB
PORTAL TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS WANTING
TO MAKE THAT TRANSITION INTO A
P. K. THROUGH TWELVE CAREER-
I'LL BE LOCKED INVESTMENT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BATTLE. THE CARD IS NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ONE
POSITION ON GOING FOR THE
COMMISSION TO CONTRACT. FOR
PUBLIC OUTREACH TO HIGHLIGHT THE
VALUE AND BENEFITS OF
EDUCATIONAL CAREER IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRE. K. THROUGH
GRADE TWELVE SCHOOL. AND GOAL
HERE IS THAT THE PMR CAREER
COUNSELOR PROBABLY OUT WE I.
KEEP THE COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER
IN A CO. SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
RECRUIT AND THE- OF THE STATE
TEACHER CAREER TYPE. EFFORT TO
REALLY AIMED AT IN. THAT ALL THE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO BECOME A
TEACHER IS THE BILL TO A PRESS.
CANDIDATES LASTLY THERE IS SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE EXTENDING
THE FLEXIBILITY FOR SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS BY AUTHORIZING ANY
HOLDER OF A CREDENTIAL PERMIT.
ISSUED BY THE COMMISSION TO
SERVE IN A SUBSTITUTE TEACHING
ASSIGNMENTS ALIGNED WITH THEIR
AUTHORIZATION INCLUDING PERTH
THAT THEY CAN SEE IT. FOR UP TO
SIXTY CUMULATIVE DAYS BEFORE
ANYONE ASSIGNMENT. BACKING COULD
MY REMARKS ON GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS THE STATE
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE SHORTAGE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU IN YOUR VALLEY OUR
GANG. SO THERE ARE SOME AND YOU
WORK FORCE FOR AND THIS I PLAN
TO THROUGH A RECOMMEND. FOR EACH
OF THESE PROPOSALS AS LISTED
STARTING ON PAGE FOURTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA. STARTING FIRST WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY TEACHER
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES WHICH
OPPOSES I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
TO CTC FOR NEW CAREER COUNSELOR
IS A NEW TEACHER RECRUITMENT WEB
PORTAL AND A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFY THESE
APOSTLES PROVIDE FUNDING TO ONE
OF THE EXISTING ENTITIES THAT
ARE ALREADY DOING THIS WORK
RATHER THAN CTC. BOTH CD II ADDS
THE CENTER ON TEACHING CAREERS
ARE READY OPERATE SEPARATE
ONLINE PLATFORMS TO RECRUIT NEW
TEACHERS TO THE PROFESSION AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
TEACHER CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENTS. THE CENTER ALSO
HAS EXPERIENCE RUNNING STATEWIDE
GROESCHEL CAMPAIGNS. THE
PROPOSED ACTIVITIES FOR CTC
WOULD. EXISTING EFFORTS RATHER
THAN ESTABLISHING ONE
COORDINATED AT THE WORD TITO I
FORM THAT ALL PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS CAN TURN TO GUIDE THEM
THROUGH THE COMP A COMPLEX
PROCESS. WE ALSO THINK THAT CD
OR THE CENTER WOULD BE BETTER
POSITIONED TO TAX WITH ME IN
RESPONSE TO PANDEMIC DRIVEN
TEACHER SHORTAGES SINCE BOTH
READY HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PARTNERSHIPS IN PLACE TO THE
GROUND RUNNING. THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER THE BEER
STREET OFFICE TO SEE IT WITH
MONEY EITHER ENTITY INCLUDING
LEVELS OF EXPERTISE
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE ONLINE
PLATFORM AND FUNDING SOURCE.
NEXT ON THE PROPOSAL TO
REESTABLISH THE PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAMS ARE
P. MATH. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
DISTRICTS ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO
PERSONAL MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE
THROUGH THE FISCAL CRISIS AND
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAM
PERFECT MATCH. AND HE'S
CURRENTLY DISTRICTS CAN REQUEST
FIGMENT TO STUDY AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO STREAMLINE
AND IMPROVE THE DISTRICTS EACH.
TEACHER HIRING PROCESS HE TO
RETENTION RATE AND SUPPLY OF
HIGHLY QUALIFIED. TEACHERS
THAT'S COULD HAVE DECENT
ESPECIALLY IF DISTRICTS CURRENT
ARE DRIVEN BY COLLECTIVE.
AGREEMENTS WHICH ARE IN LINE TO
CHANGE. I'M MOVING ON TO THE
CRASH THEME IN EXAMINE THEME.
REBEKAH SELECTING REACH BOTH
THESE FOR. WE FEES WE ARE TO
MOST R. O. MORTE TO PROFESSION
AND ADDRESS THE CURRENT TEACHER
SHORTAGES ESPECIALLY SINCE MOST
TEACHERS DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
SWEEPERS BEFORE APPLYING TO
PROGRAMS OTHER EFFORTS SUCH AS
STREAMLINING THE STATE'S COMPLEX
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS COULD
MORE EFFECTIVELY LOWER BARRIERS
TO BECOMING A TEACHER. LASTLY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A PROPOSAL FOR AN
INTEGRATED UNDERGRADUATE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS THESE
PROGRAMS OFFER A COST EFFICIENT
AND QUICKER OPTION FOR
INTERESTED UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE TRAINING AND
THEN BECOME TEACHERS AFTER
GRADUATION. I COMPLETE MY
TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR LETTER TO MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION MY NAME IS MERRY FIXIE
SANDY ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COMMISSION. ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND I'M JOINED
TODAY BY THE COMMISSION
CERTIFICATION DIRECTOR AARON
SCRUPLE IN OUR PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR DAVID FIGURE.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW REMARKS
THREE OF US WILLBE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WE MOVE
ALONG. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET INCLUDES IMPORTANT
TARGETED FUNDING THAT WILL
COMPLEMENT INVESTMENTS OF MADE
IN PRIOR YEARS. TO SUPPORT AND
DEVELOP THE TEACHING WORKFORCE
PRIMARILY IN THE FORM OF GRANTS
. STAFFING SHORTAGES HAVE BEEN
ONGOING FOR SEVERAL YEARS BUT
HAVE WORSENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. DENTAL APPLICATION
VOLUME OVERALL IS DOWN FROM THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR TO
THE PRESENT BY ALMOST 11% YOU
SEEN A DECREASE OF ABOUT 11%
OVERALL IN THESE LAST TWO YEARS
I IN OUR CREDENTIAL APPLICATION
VOLUME. DESPITE THE OVERALL
DOWNTURN HOWEVER PRELIMINARY
TEACHING CREDENTIAL APPLICATIONS
AND SERVICES CREDENTIAL
APPLICATIONS HAVE ISSUED IN THE
LAST YEAR- REFLECTED AN INCREASE
OF ABOUT 15% OVER THE PRIOR YEAR
THIS MAY BE DUE IN PART TO THE
EARLY INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN MAKING IN THE RESIDENTS
GRANT PROGRAMS THE LOCAL
SOLUTIONS. AND OTHER OTHER
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN AVAILABLE THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY PERMITS ISSUED. IN THE
LAST YEAR DECREASED BY ALMOST
HALF IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
MOSTLY LIKELY THE MOST LIKELY TO
THE INCREASED AVAILABILITY OF
FULLY CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. IN
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OF
WHICH PREPARES CLOSE TO HALF OF
THE TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS DURING THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AS WELL- THEY
DECLINED BY ABOUT 10% BETWEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK THAT WAS FOLLOWED BY ABOUT
A 24% INCREASE BETWEEN
1-920-192-2020 ONE. WE BELIEVE
THESE INCREASES IN THE NUMBERS
OF CREDENTIALS ISSUED THE
ENROLLMENTS ARE MOST LIKELY DUE
TO FLEXIBILITY AS ESTABLISHED BY
THE COMMISSION FOR EDUCATOR
PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY BY LEGISLATIVE
ACTION IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO ALLOW PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL
CANDIDATES TO DEFERRED
COMPLETION OF THEIR READING
INSTRUCTIONAL COMPETENCE
ASSESSMENT. AND TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
REQUIREMENTS AND ENTER. THE
PROFESSION. NEARLY TAKEN
TOGETHER WE BELIEVE WE INVEST
PROPOSED IN THE BY RIVER A
LITTLE EFFORTS AT THIS REGIONAL
AND LOCAL AND INDIVIDUAL LEVELS
THEY CAN SUPPORT AND GROW THE
EDUCATIONAL WORKFORCE IN THE
NEAR AND THE LONG TERM I'D LIKE
TO- JUST BRIEFLY DISCUSSED THE
BEST SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED
BY THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AS
WELL HOWEVER WE ARE
STRENGTHENING THE COMMISSION'S
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT RESPECT
RESPECTIVE EDUCATORS AS A CREEK
IS A CRITICAL NEED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OVER THE LAST
DECADE THE DEMAND FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE FROM THE COMMISSION
CERTIFICATION DIVISION HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
CURRENTLY WE RESPOND TO BETWEEN
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND EMAIL AND
ENGAGE IN ABOUT FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED ONLINE CHATS PER WEEK OF
ENGAGING WITH CANDIDATES SEEKING
INFORMATION ABOUT CREDENTIALING
A TO DATE YEAR TO DATE WE HAVE I
RESPONDED TO SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND EMAIL AND OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LIVE CHATS THIS IS
LIKELY DUE TO THE EXPANSION OF
OPTIONS AND PATHWAYS TO MEET
PRODUCTION REQUIREMENTS IN
RECENT YEARS INCLUDING
UNDERGRADUATE INTEGRATED
PREPARATION AND YOU THREE
PROGRAMS. INTERNSHIP ROUTES INTO
TEACHING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
RESIDENCIA CLASSIFIED STAFF
PATHWAYS INSTITUTION. AS WELL.
HE'S NEW OP FOR PERSPECTIVE
TEACHERS WELL AS THE REASON
EXPERIENCE OF OUR FOR ME SPACE
SKILLS AND SOME MATTER. MAY THE
PROCESS OF COULD PREPARATION AND
EARNING A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
MORE COMPLEX AND OFTEN CONFUSING
FOR PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS. THE
QUESTIONS ARE SHIFTED FROM HOW
DOES ONE BECOME A TEACHER TOO
HOW DO I BECOME A TEACHER GIVEN
MY UNIQUE SITUATION AND THE
ARRAY OF OPTIONS THAT MAKE
SENSE. MOST CAREER COUNSELORS
WILL BE DEDICATED TO CREATING AN
ONLINE SYSTEM THAT LEADS
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS THROUGH
THEIR UNIQUE QUESTIONS WHILE
ALSO PROVIDING INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT WHEN NEEDED. ACCESS TO
ONLINE INFORMATION ABOUT
PATHWAYS OPTIONS FOR MEETING
CREDENTIALS PROGRAM AND GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES COUPLED WITH
DEDICATED STAFF ASSISTANCE WILL
ASSIST ALL PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
AND NAVIGATING THE CREDENTIAL
PROCESS. THE STATE DOES NEED TO
HAVE A COORDINATED AND
AUTHORITATIVE PLATFORM
RESPONDING TO QUESTIONS AND
GUIDING THAT THE PROSPECTIVE
WORKFORCE INTO AND THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ARGUE THAT THAT
SHOULD BE THE COMMISSION A
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. THE
LICENSING AGENCY THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE BY THE CENTER FOR
TEACHING CAREERS A TULARE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION PROVIDES AN
INVALUABLE RESOURCE AND IN TERMS
OF JOB SEEKERS AND A PLATFORM
FOR JOB SEEKERS AND JOB.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CANDIDATES
SEEKING POSITIONS. THE SITE
OFFERED BY THE- HOSTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ALSO A VERY-
INVITING- WEBSITE THAT PROVIDES
VERY HIGH LEVEL INTRODUCTORY
INFORMATION ABOUT BECOMING A
TEACHER BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
GUIDING AND DEMYSTIFYING THE
PROCESS AND SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WHILE THEY MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS. I'M NOT EITHER OF THOSE
SITES CAN REALLY TAKE THE PLACE
OF THE WORK THE COMMISSION
TEACHER CREDENTIALING SHOULD BE
DOING WE BELIEVE THAT HAVING ALL
OF THOSE SITES AVAILABLE TO OUR
PROSPECTIVE EDUCATORS IS REALLY
QUITE CRITICAL DURING THIS TIME
OF SHORTAGES AND STAFFING NEEDS.
RIGHT BACK INCLUDES MY REMARKS
FOR NOW I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AS THEY COME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FROM. THAT
COMPLETES THE PAN AND WILL BE TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUITE TO
EITHER CAR HAVE QUESTIONS-
CENTER ROADSHOWS WILL. I'M
CURIOUS TO SEE FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
RESPONSE BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO WITH REGARDS
TO- MISS- ARE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE. WE ARE LOOKING FOR A
HALF DAY THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THAT'S WHO JUST
SPOKE YES BUT I DON'T HAVE HER
NAME ON OUR MERRY SANDY I'M
SORRY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I'M
SORRY SAID ADDING HAVE YOUR
NAME. ON OUR LIST HERE- BUT I'VE
I'M HERE IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
I DON'T HAVE TO HAVE ANY
FEEDBACK ON YOUR RESPONSE. SURE
HAPPY TO WEIGH IN ON THAT
ANYBODY FROM ALABAMA SO I THINK
DOCTOR SANDY'S COMMENTS ARE WILL
TAKE AND I THINK. THAT THE MAIN
CONCERN IS THAT WHEN INDIVIDUALS
ARE INTERESTED IN THE TEACHING
PROFESSION ARE REACHING OUT TO
CDC THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE READY TO THINKING ABOUT
BECOMING A TEACHER I THINK OUR
OR COMMENTS OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE. ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
BROADER POOL OF TEACHERS AND
ATTRACTING MORE FEATURES THAT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE THINKING
ABOUT- TEACHING TO PUT THAT ON
THE RADAR AND TO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE INFORMATION THAT
IS ACCESSIBLE AND AVAILABLE TO
THEM- IF THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT
SERIOUSLY PURSUING THIS CAREER
SO I THINK WE ARE WE ARE KIND OF
TALKING ABOUT SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
POOLS OF INDIVIDUALS HERE- I
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THAT CDC
WOULD BE ABOUT THE WORD OF THE
YEAR SOFT SOURCE WHEN IT COMES
TO. INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT
CREDENTIALING AND LICENSING BUT
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
ALREADY ONLINE PLATFORMS THAT
ARE ARE GEARED TOWARDS THAT
BROADER AUDIENCE TO EXPERIENCE
THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS THAT WE
HAD ACTUALLY PURSUING THIS TYPE
FINE.WRITING JUST SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT- TAKES ON ON ON WHAT
THAT PROBLEMS THAT THE SEAT IS
CURRENTLY FACING IS RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION AND I'VE JUST BEEN
INFORMED THAT I. MADE AND THAT
IS A DRAFT SO I APOLOGIZE ON
THAT FRONT OUR FAULT- THE LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR THE C. D.
C. WAS. VERY INTERESTING
LAST- I KNOW OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING YESTERDAY TO HEAR THAT
ONE O THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THAT THEY HAVE IN RECRUITMENT
STAFFING. IS DUE TO THE COST OF
HOUSING IN THE AREA WOULD YOU
MIND SHARING WITH THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES ARE FOR TEACHER
RECRUITMENT AT THIS TIME- IN
YOUR- IN YOUR-IN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL OPINION. AND I
GUESS A FOLLOW UP AS WELL THIS
IS THE- HAVE ANY DATA THE REGION
TEACHERS. THE REASON- WHAT ARE
THE LARGEST AIR STRIPS FOR A-
FRIEDMAN AT THE MOMENT I THINK
THAT IT'S HARD TO SAY IN A CODE
MOMENT EXACTLY- UNICODE HAS HAS
REALLY PUT A STRAIN ON
EVERYTHING- THAT WE'RE FACING I
BELIEVE THAT- WE ARE SEEN
INCREASES IN APPLICATIONS GOOD.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
TEACHING- SO IS SO THAT YOU KNOW
ALREADY SOME OF THE NARRATIVE IN
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR CANDIDATES TO
COMPLETE PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
THE RESIDENCY GRANT WORK HI IS
CREATING A WHOLE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SUPPORTS
CANDIDATES WHO ARE LOCALLY
RECRUITED AS AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK. INSIDE OF
CORPORATE TEACHERS CLASSROOM
WHILE THEY COMPLETE THEIR
CREDENTIAL WORKING WITH A LOCAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM
THESE KINDS OF RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS ARE PROVING TO BE. VERY
IMPORTANT SUBSTANTIVE-
INVESTMENTS IN OUR IN SUPPORTING
PEOPLE COMING IN. THAT THE
RECENT- EFFORTS TO REDUCE
BARRIERS FOR ENTRY INTO TEACHER
PREPARATION AB ONE THIRTY LAST
YEAR. I HAVE REALLY I THINK ALSO
HELP TO CHANGE SOME OF THE
NARRATIVE ABOUT HOW HARD IT IS
TO GET INTO TEACHING. BY
ALLOWING A GREATER- MANY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO
DEMONSTRATE BASIC SKILLS
COMPETENCE FOR INSTANCE WHERE
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCE THESE
ARE GOING TO BE. OF I THINK
BERRIER REDUCERS FOR THE
POPULATIONS TEACHERS WHO MIGHT
WANT TO COME INTO TEACHING- AND
IT BECOMES MORE INVITING- IN
MANY WAYS WHEN SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS ARE REMOVED AND WHEN
THEIR SUPPORT. AND GOOD POSITIVE
NARRATIVE IN THE FIELD ABOUT WHY
TEACH I THINK THE OTHER T.
INVESTMENT THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
AS THE NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
OUTREACH. TO HELP. TO AMPLIFY
REALLY THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION INTENDS TO DO WITH
DEVELOPING ITS WEBSITE IN ITS
CAREER COUNSELOR- AND
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN HERE. ARE
WORKING WITH THE CENTER FOR
TEACHING CAREERS AND AMPLIFYING
THE- THE KIND OF THE MESSAGING.
AROUND WHY TEACH. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ABOUT ON. SYSTEM TRIP
MANY MANY MAY TV PEOPLE ARE
COMPLETE COLLEGE LOOKING FOR
WHAT CAN I DO TO CONTRIBUTE- AND
THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT REASONS PEOPLE ELECT
TO COME INTO TEACHING SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE- WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES HERE TO
AMPLIFY THAT AND COORDINATE OUR
EFFORTS TO REACH OUT AND GET
THAT. WE DO HAVE INFORMATION AS
TO YOUR SECOND QUESTION. OUR IN
OUR DATA SETS I THINK THIS IS
PRIMARILY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHERE THE HIGHEST-
MAKE THE COUNTIES WITH THE
LARGEST DEMAND AND FORTY
TEACHERS EVERY YEAR WE GET A
REPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THAT. PROJECTS
EXPECTED HIRES FOR THE COMING
YEAR AND THAT- THERE ARE TOP TEN
COUNTIES OF DEBT THAT ARE LISTED
IN THAT IN THAT DATA AND ON OUR
DASHBOARD YOU'D BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP AND GIVE YOU. THAT
INFORMATION NOW. AT A LATER DATE
. I THINK IF. DOES THAT POINT
YOUR QUESTION. THEN I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- HERE AND
FIRST IS FOR THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING- WE LAST
YEAR BOUGHT IN THESE HEARINGS
ASKED ABOUT. OUR TEACHER SUPPLY
AND THERE WAS A LAG IN
STATISTICS AND SO WE COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT HOW THE PANDEMIC
HAD AFFECTED TEACHER SUPPLY AND
I HEARD YOUR COMMENTS IN YOUR
PRESENTATION AND THEY WERE IN
MANY WAYS- SPEAKING TO HOW. ARE
SOME TIME PERIODS ADMIN
SHORTENED HER THINGS HAD BEEN
HAPPENED TO MOVE PEOPLE LAND BUT
IF YOU STAND BACK AND LOOK AT
THE GLOBAL ISSUE OF TEACHER
SUPPLY HOW COULD YOU EXPLAIN
THOSE STATISTICS AND WHAT IT
TELLS US IS THERE STILL. A
SHORTAGE PEOPLE COMING INTO THAT
EXPEDITE PEOPLE BUT DIDN'T
ADDRESS SOME BASIC SHORTAGE
ISSUES COULD YOU COMMENT ON THAT
. SURE SO WHEN IT WHEN TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN WE CLOSED EVERYTHING
DOWN. IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
COVERT NINETEEN OF WE RAN INTO
AN IMMEDIATE PROBLEM ND I THINK
WE DISCUSSED THIS PERHAPS LAST
YEAR AT A BUDGET HEARING AS WELL
BUT THE IMMEDIATE PROBLEM WAS
THAT WE DID WAS TESTING OF ALL
THINGS. THAT WE COULD NOT
EITHER- ALLOW THE COHORT OF
TEACHERS WHO WERE ENROLLED IN
TEACHER PREPARATION TO COMPLETE
THEIR PREPARATION AS OF MARCH OF
LAST YEAR THEY COULDN'T GET
ACCESS TO TESTING CENTERS TO
TAKE THEIR FINAL EXAMINATIONS-
IF THEY COULDN'T GET ACCESS TO
CLASSROOMS TO COMPLETE THEIR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS- STUDENT
TEACHING. OPPORTUNITIES SO THE
WORK FOR SERVICE IN PREPARATION
AND ABOUT TO BE CREDENTIAL WAS
STUCK. AND ANYONE WHO IS SEEKING
TO APPLY FOR ENTRY INTO TEACHER
PREPARATION AT THAT TIME WAS
ALSO STRUCK BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T TAKE ENTRANCE
EXAMINATIONS THE BASIC SKILLS
TEST WHERE THAT THE SUBJECT
MATTER TESTS. THE TESTING BECAME
THE BARRIER THAT THAT FROZE OUR
PIPELINE RIGHT THEN AND THERE
AND SO WHAT WE HAD TO DO WAS I
WAS AND WE WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET THIS DONE. OF
FIRST OFF WAS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT REMOVED TESTING IS AN
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENT FOR
PREPARATION. OF ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO ADD TO BE ADMITTED TO
PREPARATION WITH THE PROVISO
THAT THEY COMPLETE THEIR BASIC
SKILLS AND SUBJECT MATTER BEFORE
THEY GET THEIR CREDENTIAL BUT IT
ALLOWED PEOPLE TO ENTER
PREPARATION. IN TWENTY OF
TWENTY- INTERN OF PEOPLE. PRINT
USING WORSE. ORDER ALSO ALLOWED
. FOR I. T. TO. THEIR READING
INSTRUCTIONAL COMPETENCE
ASSESSMENT WHICH THEY NEEDED
SAKE IN  TESTING CENTER. SO
THEY CAN DEFERRED FOR UP TO FIVE
YEARS GET THEIR PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIAL AND BEGIN TEACHING. A
COMPLETE THAT WITHIN THE FIVE
YEARS THAT THEY NEEDED TO EARN
THEIR CLEAR TEACHING CREDENTIAL.
SIMILARLY WITH THE TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT WHICH
REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE A
CLASSROOM WHERE THEY CAN. THEY
CAN DO THE WORK THAT'S NECESSARY
TO ASSEMBLE THE MATERIALS FOR
THAT PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT.
WITHOUT A CLASSROOM MANY WEAK
MANY INNOVATIONS EMERGED IN THAT
MOMENT WHERE WE LOOK AT HOW CAN
ONLINE LEARNING SO YOU KNOW
SUBSTITUTE FOR IN CLASSROOM
EXPERIENCE THAT WE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THAT. BUT DEFERRING THOSE
ASSESSMENTS ENABLE THAT
POPULATION TO GET IN. TWO OF THE
TEACHING PROFESSION BE AVAILABLE
AS EARLY AS THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR- YES AS
TEACHERS. THESE WERE VERY
IMPORTANT SHIFTS HERE I
APPRECIATE HOW IMPORTANT DOES
WORK I'M STILL TRYING TO GET A
PICTURE OF WHAT THE GLOBAL
SITUATION IS. A. N. N. A. N. IF
IT'S JUST AT THE DATA CAN'T TELL
YOU THAT THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO
KNOW BECAUSE- IF YOU JUST GOT
ALL THIS RAW DATA THAT DOESN'T
GIVE YOU. ANY WAY TO BREAK DOWN.
THE HOUSE SOME PEOPLE WERE
EXPEDITED HOW THEY WEREN'T A
PART. REALLY OVERALL. ARE WE
SEEING. MORE RETIREMENTS THAN
THERE ARE NEW TEACHERS IN. CAR
AND IN ROME AT SHIFTING AND
PLACES THAT THAT. DICTATES A
SHORTAGE I AM TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IT'S THE
PERFECT BACKDROP. FOR THE
DISCUSSION OF THIS ITEM. WELL
THE TEST I GUESS SINCE TEST IS A
BARRIER. THAT AND SOME OF THE
CHANGE THAT OCCURRED LAST YEAR-
IN. ENABLING FLEX AROUND THIS
TESTING REQUIREMENTS SHOULD HELP
BUT THE FACT THAT- WE SAW A 15%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
TEACHING CREDENTIALS WE WERE
ABLE THE ISSUE. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR WHICH IS WHAT I
SHARED EARLIER- IT. SUGGESTIVE
ADDED ON ON UNDERSTANDING THE
CONTEXT FOR THAT IS THAT A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THE
PREVIOUS YEAR BECAUSE COVERED
REALLY DEPRESSED AT AND OVERALL
WE'RE STILL. REALLY HAVING A
SHORTAGE AND NOT PROCESSING AS
MANY PEOPLE AS ROOF RETIRING I'M
TRYING TO LOOK FOR THE OVERALL
SHARON TAX. SO SUMMARY AND WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS THAT THESE ARE IT
REGARDING DECATUR'S AT THIS
POINT INDICATORS THAT WE NEED TO
GO DEEPER AND WE NEED TO DO
DEEPER WORK TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT. WERE THE ROOT CAUSES THAT
ENABLE MORE PEOPLE TO COME AND
GET CREDENTIALS THAN BEFORE WE
HAVE A STRONG SUSPICION THAT
LAMINATING TESTING. BARRIERS FOR
ENTRY AND FOR EXIT. HELPED IN
THE AND GAVE US 15% MORE LAST
YEAR THAN WE THAN WE HAVE THE
PRIOR YEAR- SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THE LEGISLATURE SEE I'M STILL
NOT UNDERSTANDING THE CONTEXT
FOR THAT I THINK. I'M SORT OF
GATHERING I'M NOT GOING TO GET
IT RIGHT NOW SO LET ME JUST MAKE
CLEAR STATEMENT. THAT THAT. WE
REALLY WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
THESE PROPOSALS FOR WAIVERS AND
OTHER THINGS. WHAT'S OUR OVERALL
SITUATION OR MANY MORE TEACHERS
RETIRING THAT ARE COMING IN WAS
THE BOB DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGHER AND THE PROBLEM MADE MORE
ACUTE BY THE PANDEMIC. ARE SO
THAT WE KNOW THAT ONE WERE
ASKING BEING ASKED TO SUPPORT
FINANCIAL WE- ARE THINGS THAT
EXPEDITE TEACHERS WERE CONVINCED
TEACHERS TO COME IN MIKE HAVE
CHOSEN TEACHING OR WHATEVER IT
IS THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT AGAINST THE GLOBAL
PROBLEM OF THE SENATE IF IT
TURNS OUT. YOU DON'T KEEP THOSE
TO STATISTICS IN THE RIGHT WAY
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHO DOES
OR HOW TO DISTILL THEM OR HOW TO
GET THERE BUT THAT'S- THE THAT'S
THE I THINK THE ISSUE FOR US
WELL LET ME. GIVE YOU JUST ONE
MORE THING BEFORE YOU DO SENATOR
THERE BUT IN TERMS OF
RETIREMENTS WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
DATA THAT CASTERS DOES LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A PROJECTED- NUMBER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND POSSIBLE
RETIREMENTS THIS TIME LAST YEAR
WE ACTUALLY SAW BASED ON CASTERS
DATA ABOUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED. TEACHERS WE WE'VE
SEEN- WE'RE SEEING- OF HOLES IN
OF THE TEACHING POPULATION HOW
MANY OF YOU ARE TEACHERS ARE
PLANNING TO STAY. OR LEAVE THE
PROFESSION AND THOSE NUMBERS
DURING THIS YEAR OF RE OPENING
SCHOOLS- ARE ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE IT COULD BE AS MANY AS 21%
OF THE TEACHERS AT THE TIME THAT
THEY WERE SURVEYED SAID I DON'T
KNOW THAT I CAN STAND THIS FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. BUT THIS YEAR HAS
BEEN VOLATILE IN THAT RESPECT
AND YOU NEVER RESPECT SO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT SIR THAT'S
ALL WE DON'T KNOW OKAY. THAT'S
HAPPENING. JOHNSON WITH THE
STATUS THIS YEAR TO. AS HE IS-
WON ME ARE THEM BE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND EVEN IF
YOU'RE NOT READY NOW US SINCE
THE CREDENTIALING ONLY HAS PART
OF THE ISSUE IT'S PEOPLE COMING
IN OR OR STOPPING WITH
CREDENTIALS AND THERE'S NOT THE
RETIREMENT INFORMATION DO YOU
MONITOR THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
TOWARD THIS QUESTION OF WHERE WE
ARE. ON TEACHER SUPPLY. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATE
EARLIER IT'S I THINK THIS IS- A
QUINTESSENTIAL QUESTION WHEN IT
COMES TO TEACHING ISSUES TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S- THE
TEACHER SUPPLY LOOKS LIKE
COMPARED TO THE DEMANDS I DON'T
THINK JUST GIVEN THE AVAILABLE
TO SEE DATA WE'VE EVER HAD A
GOOD GRASP OF THAT INFORMATION.
AND WE USUALLY DO LOOK AT
INDICATORS SUCH AS THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY- WAIVERS AND PRETEND
AND- AND URGENCY CREDENTIALS ARE
ISSUED FROM YEAR TO YEAR WE CAN
USUALLY LOOK ADDS- HOW OLD DAY
NUMBER OF NEWLY ISSUED
CREDENTIALS COMPARES TO THE
PROJECTED. NUMBER OF ESTIMATED
HIGHER IS THAT DISTRICTS ARE
ASKING FOR ANY YEAR TO YEAR
BASIS- BUT WE DON'T WE DON'T
TYPICALLY HAVE AN EASY GO TO
WHEN IT COMES TO ASSESSING WHAT
AND I TEACHER SHORTAGES LOOK
LIKE OR WHETHER OR NOT. THERE IS
A TEACHER SHORTAGE OR AN
OVERSUPPLY AND I THINK PART OF
THAT ADDITIONAL COMPLICATION
WITH. DATA RECENT YEARS IS JUST
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND NOT
KNOWING WHETHER OR NOT THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC WILL BE
SHORT LASTING OR LONG LASTING I
THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO IT THE
AVAILABILITY OF DATA. BUT
THEY'RE ALSO ISSUES THAT ARE
RELATED TO- SORT OF THAT THE
VERY SPECIFIC AS CHANGING COULD
NATURE OF THE PANDEMIC RIGHT NOW
THAT I THINK MAKES IT REALLY
HARD TO UNDERSTAND FROM A GLOBAL
CONTACTS WHETHER OR NOT.
DISTRICTS HAVE ACCESS TO. FULLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS THAT THEY
NEED TO FOR THE CLASSROOMS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
I THINK IT JUST GOES WITHOUT
SAYING THAT. THAT WERE REALLY
INTERESTED IN THIS AND IF HAVING
A SENSE OF THIS WOULD GOVERN OF
POLIY ACTIONS WE WOULD WANT TO
TAKE. LET ME ASK. ONE QUESTION
AND A NEW. ARENA TO THE OF
FINDING AND TO THE- COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING. OUR
BIG YOU MENTIONED OUT EFFORTS
CAREER COUNSELORS AND ROADSHOW
BARGAIN I WERE AT A RECEPTION
LAST NIGHT AND I MET SOMEBODY
FROM SOME NONPROFIT THAT. IS
DETERMINED TO OUR MAKE SURE
THERE IS A BLACK TEACHER IN. ARE
JUST ALL THE SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE IN A WAY THAT THE
REPRESENTED PEOPLE SEE THEM AS
ROLE MODELS. ON THE OUTREACH
EFFORTS THAT ARE DESCRIBED HERE.
AND THE CAREER COUNSELORS. HOW
DO YOU KNOW THAT OR HOW DO YOU.
I TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
REACHING OUT TO RECRUIT MORE
TEACHERS OF COLOR. AND WHAT'S
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YEAH. APOLOGY I'M MAKE THE BODY
PART OF FINANCE SO ALL OF THESE
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
ARE INTENDED TO INCLUDE AND
SUPPORT A DIVERSE EDUCATED
WORKFORCE. AND THE PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT AT THE THIRTEENTH OR
P. MAC PROGRAM WILL BE FOCUSED
ON PROVIDING LOCALIZED
ASSISTANCE TO EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH THEIR PERSONNEL
RECRUITMENT AND HIRING NEEDS AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT IN MANY AREAS
OF THE STATE FOR TREATMENT OF
TEACHERS OF COLOR WILL BE A
STAFFING NEEDS THAT THE TEAM
THAT WILL. HELP YEAH- ASSIST IN
ADDRESSING ADDITIONALLY WE NOTE
THAT THE NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AREN'T GOING GENERAL FUND THAT
IS PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH WILL
BE INFORMED BY THE WORK OF THE
P. MAX AND THEIR RECORD AFTER IT
UNTIL IF THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OR
NATIONAL POPULATIONS NEED TO BE
TARGETED FOR MORE INTENSE ABOUT
REACHED. THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE DOES PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THAT TO OCCUR
AND IN THOSE INSTANCES THE
COMMISSION WILL INCLUDE
INFORMATION AROUND WIDELY
SPECIAL TARGETING WAS NEEDED IN
THE BI ANNUAL REPORT THAT IS DUE
TO FINANCE. AND THIS INVESTMENT
IS INTENDED TO BE FLEXIBLE SO
THAT THE PBLIC OUT REACH CAN BE
RESPONSIVE AS AS NEED THE BALL
AND AN ALTERNATE OVER TO THE
COMMISSION TO EXPAND IF
NECESSARY UPON SOME OF THE
EFFORT THEY ARE UNDERTAKING IN
THIS AREA MASSLESS WHAT'S THE
COMMISSION YOU HAVE ANY. TO THAT
. WHAT ARE WE ARE WE'VE GOT.
WHAT MADE JUST HANG SAID THE
GRANT. THAT GONNA- CALL FOR US
AND DIRECT US TO. PRIVILEGE-
EFFORTS TO RECRUITED. MARKET T.
SO HAVE THE OP. THROUGH THE REST
TO GROW TO DO IN. AND REPORT ON
THAT BUT ALSO SAY THAT PRO- THIS
IS IN X. SUPPORT FOR COMMISSION
. WILL GIVE US- STAFF TO
ADMINISTER THESE FOR PROGRAM AND
TO GET INTO THE AND BEGIN TO
CALL. AND PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
LOOK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
REGIONAL LEVELS- IN ADDITION TO
THAT THE PERSONAL MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAMS. AND THE DATA
OTHER DATA POSITIONS ALSO PROVED
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET THAT ARE WILL
HELP US BEGIN TO TODAY AGAIN AND
COLLECT THE KINDS OF DATA. ON
THE IMPACT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE THAT YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT
AND- WE ARE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHIP
FOR LIGHT AND TO BE VERY.
PROACTIVE IN USING THESE
RESOURCES TO DIVERSIFY THE
WORKFORCE THANK YOU RINPOCHE
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION AND
JUST. NOTE THAT. THE MORE REAL%
COMMITTED TO THAT TO JUST HOPE
TO SEE THAT IN INDIA. ANY
FURTHER. FROM MY COLLEAGUES HERE
. SEEING NONE OF LET ME THANK OF
THE PANEL ON THE ISSUE FOR WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE ISSUE FIVE
IN THE FINAL ISSUE ON THIS-
HEARINGS AGENDA. OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS
AND I'VE LISTED OF FOUR PEOPLE
ON THE PANEL A JENNIFER KACU
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DAN HANNAH OUR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE POSTING
HOUSING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND WAS AT
NAVARETTE FROM THE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND WILL GROW IN THAT
ORDER. AND WELCOME MISS KACU
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF. I KNOW
FOR THE FIRST DAY IN HANOI
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
PROPOSALS DESIGNED TO PREPARE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE FOR TWO
SPECIFIC FIELDS PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE FIRST IS FOR- ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND OF WHICH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. FIFTY
MILLION IS FOR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND FIFTY
MILLION THIS FOR TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE DESPITE
HEALTHCARE FOCUSED VOCATIONAL
PATHWAYS FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS ACROSS ALL LEVELS OF
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
DEVELOP PATHWAYS FOCUSED ON
LOCAL PROGRAMS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT HEALTH CARE AND CARE
HEALTH CARE AND CARA CONNIE WORK
FORCE NEEDS. THE SECOND IS FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE CC AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. THIS WILL BUILD ON A
PILOT PROGRAM AND ALLOW FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF COLLABORATIVES
THEY'LL OFFER THE OFFERING OF
TEACHER CREDENTIAL COURSEWORK
REMOTELY. MY COLLEAGUE JEN
COCULA WHO COVERS ADULT
EDUCATION ISSUES AND I ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT THE SYMPTOMS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- OF APPRECIATE
THAT WILL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU PAUL STATE HOUSE AND
WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
CALLED FIRST TALK ABOUT THE
ADULT EDUCATION. PROGRAM
PROPOSED PROPOSAL AS THE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME.
THAT YOUJUST HEARD ABOUT AND
THEN I'LL TALK ABOUT THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PARTNERSHIP.
PROGRAM SO ON ADULT EDUCATION
YOU KNOW THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARD
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO ABOUT HOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT.
HAD DECLINED NOTABLY- AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC. WELL IN
A MOMENT IN ADULT EDUCATION
WHICH FOCUSES ON PRE COLLEGIATE
LEVEL- INSTRUCTION AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING. HAS ACTUALLY DECLINED
EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANTLY. AS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES ON PAGES SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGH THEIR ADULT SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE NON
CREDIT PROGRAMS. SERVED ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND OR ONE THIRD
FEWER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS COMPARED WITH
OTHER NUMBER THEY WERE SERVING
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC OCCURRED.
AND BASED ON PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION ADULT EDUCATION
ROMAN IS RECOVERING SLIGHTLY AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUT PROVIDERS ARE
STILL WELL BELOW- SERVING THE
PRE PANDEMIC LEVEL OF STUDENTS.
NO IN. HAS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY PROVIDERS THAT ARE
FUNDED BY ADULT EDUCATION
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM HAVE NOT
SEEN A REDUCTION IN THEIR
FUNDING AND THAT'S BECAUSE
STATUTE PROVIDES OF THOSE
PROVIDERS FUNDED BY THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM- THEM OUT-
WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ENROLLMENT LEVEL SO THEY JUST
IT'S A SET AMOUNT KIND OF BLOCK.
A SET AMOUNT THAT GOES OUT TO
THESE- ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS. AS A RESULT- ADULT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY KERR
COLLEGE IS LIKELY WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CAPACITY NEXT YEAR
TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS AND
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
CLASSES. IN VOCATIONAL COURSES
SUCH AS HEALTH CARE PATHWAYS. OF
MR HANAUER MENTIONED. THEY'RE
GONNA THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SEE CAPACITY AND THUS DON'T NEED
AN AUGMENTATION AS PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR. SO WE JUST
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
INSTEAD REDIRECT THE FUNDS TO
HIGHER PRIORITY PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PURPOSES. ON THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP. AS YOU JANET NOTES
ON PAGE SEVENTEEN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PROVIDED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF ONE TIME FOR THREE-
PILOT GRANT PROGRAMS IN. THE
GRANT WAS SET UP TO ALLOW ITS
FIERY TEACHERS WHO ALREADY HAVE
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE. TO DRIVE TO
A PARTICIPATING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THERE THE STUDENT
WOULD SET IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSROOM OR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COMPUTER LAB AND TAKE ONLINE.
TEACHER PREPARATION COURSE WORK
THROUGH A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OR OTHER UNIVERSITY
TEACHING PROGRAM. SO THESE ARE
NOT CALIFORNIA MAKE COLLEGE
STUDENTS THEIR STUDENTS OF A
POST BACCALAUREATE TEACHER PREP
PROGRAM. NOW STATUTE REQUIRES
OUR OFFICE TO EVALUATE THESE
THREE PROGRAMS OTHER CURRENTLY
BEING FUNDED. PART IS DUE TO
ALLEGED BY. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
SO BUT A YEAR FROM NOW. AS FAR
AS THE PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- TO ADD
ANOTHER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- WE
THINK IT WOULD BE PREMATURE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE MORE
GRANT FUNDING AND REMOVE IT AS A
PILOT. BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE'S
HAD A CHANCE TO. REVIEW THIS
INITIATIVE AND THIS PROGRAM
MODEL. NO THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE GIVEN HOW MUCH THINGS HAVE
CHANGED SINCE THE LEGISLATURE
ORIGINALLY CREATED AND FUNDED
THIS PILOT. YOU KNOW NOWADAYS
WITH ONLINE CLASSES TAKEN. FROM
HOME IS UBIQUITOUS AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC GIVEN THE
STATE'S SIGNIFICANT- INVESTMENT
IN FREE LAPTOPS FOR STUDENTS AND
INVESTMENTS IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE- TO INCREASE
ACCESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
THE INTERNET. SO WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE HOLD OFF IN THE
BUDGET YEAR ON FINDING ANOTHER
ROUND OF THESE GRANTS UNTIL
LEGISLATURE HAS A CHANCE TO
LEARN MORE. ABOUT THE NEED FOR
FUTURE PREPARATION- ABOUT THE
NEED FOR TEACHER PREPARATION
STUDENTS ARE TAKING ONLINE
UNIVERSITY CLASSES AT A-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- CLASSROOM AT
UNITY COLLEGE LOCATION. AND WE
HOPE ARE VERY POOR OFFICE IS
REQUIRED TO DO NEXT YEAR I WILL
HELP THE LEGISLATURE ITS REVIEW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
NORMAL TO CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE CANDLE IS THAT WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
CALIFORNIA IN COLLEGE- TRANSFER
STUDENTS. IN TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OR CSU AVERAGE 65%
OVER THE PAST DECADE GIVEN THIS
CONTEXT DATA THE CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGES IN THE CSU ARE NATURAL
PARTNERS IN TEACHER PREPARATION
PATHWAYS. AS WAS MENTIONED AT
THE BEGINNING A COLLEGE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM IS LIMITED
IN SCOPE AND WAS DEVELOPED PRIOR
TO THE HEALTH PANDEMIC TO BUILD
ON THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FOCUS ON RURAL COMMUNITIES OR
COMMUNITIES WITH LIMITED TO NO
ACCESS TO SEE ISSUES- AND
ESPECIALLY TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS. THE PROGRAMS JUST
COMPLETED A ONE YEAR PLANNING
PHASE ON THIS FALL WHILE IT'S
EARLY TO HAVE EACH AND AN
ACHIEVEMENT MEASURES THE THREE
DISTRICTS OFFERING THE PILOTS
RIVER. THE COLLEGE AND MONTEREY
PENINSULA COLLEGE REMAIN ON
TRACK TO SERVE FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE STUDENTS PER SITE THE
PROGRAM IS SERVING CANDIDATES
WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE- HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT ARE TEACHING OR HAVE
LIMITED CREDENTIAL- THE-
OFFERINGS- IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WITH THE GOAL OF KEEPING THEM
THERE- TO SERVE AGAIN. A RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND OUR STUDENTS
THAT HAVE A LIMITED ACCESS TO
TEACHERS WE CONTINUE TO LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS IN THE
YEAR AHEAD HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A TO THE PANEL. THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ASK ANY.
QUESTIONS DO I HAVE ANY. SENATOR
MEN. SURE TO RELATED- YEAH I
THOUGHT THAT THE A. O. COMMA
WERE VERY AND I I'M WANT TO DATE
HEAR WHAT THE- AND IF I.
RESPONSIVE BE TO THOSE. AND
DINNER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
DOESN'T A POINT OF CLARIFCATION
- FOR WHICH OF THE TWO
PROPOSALS- OR FOR BOESER.
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO DO THIS BUT
YEAH I MEAN I THINK IT DAILY-
RECOMMENDED THAT WE- REJECT THE
ADULT EDUCATION ISSUES AS WELL
AS THE TEA I THINK THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING- NOT I THINK. IT
WAS REJECTING BOTH THE RIGHT.
THE. YEAH I DON'T EDUCATION ONLY
RESIDE NOW YEAH IN PARTICULAR
THE BILL THAT PIECE. THANK YOU
IDENTIFY CALLING. SIX O'CLOCK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF. I'M
CENTER MEN I'LL DO MY BEST TO
KIND OF FIRST JUST OF THE- SOME
OF THE COMMENTS IN JUST REALLY-
AT THE SIZE THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM- THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY TO ADDRESS THE
OVERALL SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. THAT THE STATE IS
FACING WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
UPSKILLING AN EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAY OPPORTUNITIES
PARTICULARLY FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. HOPE EXPAND
YOU KNOW DIVERSITY IN THIS WORK
FORCE AREA- YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM
AND WE AND WE STRIVE TO REALLY-
YOU KNOW HAD HANDLED THIS ISSUE-
AND- YEAH DO YOU HAVE. I MEAN I
THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH THE
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW I GUESS MY CONCERN
THAT THE L. A. OVER HAS RAISED
IS. THAT YOU'RE JUST THROWING
MONEY INTO A PROGRAM WITHOUT A
LOT OF- FORESIGHT OR
THOUGHTFULNESS. AND THAT THAT
DOES RAISE REAL CONCERNS THAT
THAT THERE'S NOT A DEMAND FOR
THIS. SIDE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
EXCESS CAPACITY AT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT YOU'RE
ENVISIONING PUTTING MORE MONEY
INTO- AND SO JUST AS I REYES
SIMILAR COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FIRST ISSUE. YOU KNOW
I AM WONDERING IF YOU HAVE ANY
DATA TO SUGGEST. THAT THE
ALEJO'S CONCERNS ARE MISPLACED.
THAT THERE IS NOT A CAPACITY
EXCESS THAT THERE SHOULD NOT BE
CONCERNED ABOUT ENROLLMENT.THAT
BAD DO YOU HAVE SOME BASIS FOR
SAYING. THAT THIS PROGRAM THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET AT A
ALLOCATION. WILL ACTUALLY SERVE
THE PURPOSES THAT YOU INTENDED
TO SIR LIKE WE ALL WE WANT MORE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS RIGHT NOW
THAT'S THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT- BY. JUST THROWING A
BUNCH OF MONEY AT A PROBLEM
DOESN'T MAKE IT ACTUALLY GET
FIXED AND SO I'M I'M WONDERING
SAID WHAT WHAT THE RATIONALE IS.
SPECIFICALLY RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE L. A.
L. OKAY SO- TO KIND OF ADDRESS
WE ARE MONITORING THE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS WITH US AT THIS
CURRENT TIME- BUT WE ARE THAT IS
SOMETHING. WE'RE TRACKING-
HOWEVER YOU KNOW THESE FUNDS
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE REALLY TO
ESTABLISH- THESE TYPES OF OR OR
EXPAND FEES VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS-
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES SO THAT THEY CAN
BEGIN. YOU KNOW BY NOW. EXCUSE
ME IF I CAN ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION I THINK WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO CLARIFY. IS WHAT GOES
TO ALL ADULT EDUCATION NOW. AND
WHAT IS BEING ADDED AND WHAT IS
BIG TARGETED FOR THE ADDITIONS
SO THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE THE THING
IS THAT. ARE I STRONGLY. SUPPORT
ADULT EDUCATION FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS BECAUSE IT.
ALLOWS SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DON'T. ARM
BUT FOR THE HEALTH. WORKER OF
SERIES I KNOW COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE BETTER POSITIONED TO DO THAT
SO I'M TRYING TO. UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S DONE NOW WHAT WITH THIS
ADDED WHY YOU DECIDED TO DO. IT
HERE AND NOT TO HELP WORK WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR- OR OTHER
THINGS SO. IT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. WHAT'S BE
GIVEN TO A EDUCATION NOW AND HOW
THE SAID. YEAH SO- SO THE
CURRENT- EDUCATION PROGRAM
RECEIVES- SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- AND THEN THIS
INVESTMENT WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON TOP OF THAT- SO THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS-
ALLOCATED PUTA WITH WITHIN THE
CONSORT OF THE ADULT EDUCATION
WILL BE CALLED THE CONSORTIUM.
SO THEY WILL DISPERSE THE FINES-
YOU KNOW BASED ON THEIR OWN
CALCULATIONS THAT THEY USE-
THROUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- AND THEY REALLY WORK
WORK BUG THROUGH BY A VALUE
WAITING THEIR OWN REGIONAL NEEDS
TO KIND OF PROVIDE THE TYPES OF
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES THAT THAT
REGION WILL BE ME. THANK YOU- ME
JUST THAT GIVE FOCUS TO CENTER
MAN QUEST BECAUSE- IF. WE'RE
GIVING SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND
THERE'S DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
THIS IS PROPOSING TO ADD SO HOW
- BASED ON THE STATISTICS OF THE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IS THIS
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
ARE THEY THE APPROPRIATE ONES TO
DO I HINK THEY ARE FOR THE-ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS I
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY ARE FOR.
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
NECESSARILY HOW HOW IS THIS
JUSTIFIED GIVEN THE ENROLLMENT
AND WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO PUT
ALL OF IT FOR ADULT EDUCATION
NOT SEGMENTS AND IF I MIGHT ADD
JUST ONE FOLLOW UP YOU HAVE LIKE
A HAT WHAT WAS THAT Y. ONE
THIRTY Y. NOT ONE FIFTY ONE NOT
NINETY SO WHAT WAS THE BASIS FOR
THAT NUMBER. OKAY BUT I KIND OF
THINK OF YOU ANSWER THE FIRST
PART THEY'LL START TO GET TO THE
SECOND I DON'T THINK OF IT THE
SECOND WORK ON THE- LET'S SEE
WHAT YOU BETTER ANSWER QUICKLY
SO THAT YOU CAN CUT OUT THIS BY. OF THIS SIDE CONVERSATION HERE
- SO I'LL- YOU KNOW I'LL DO MY
BEST ADDRESS US. YOU KNOW THE
VARIOUS QUESTIONS OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW SO FOR THE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
REALLY WITH IN THE AVAILABLE
PROP NINETY EIGHT RESOURCES- AND
THEN TO KIND OF. ADDRESS THE-
THE QUESTIONS AREN'T YOU KNOW.
THIS MAKING SENSE WITHIN THE
GRAND SCHEME OF BUT- EDUCATION
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY A COMPONENT
OF THE ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR CARE ECONOMY WORKFORCE
PACKAGE THAT REALLY. DISNEY THAT
REALLY SERVES TO CREATE MORE
INNOVATIVE AND ACCESSIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO RECRUIT TRAIN
HIGHER AND ADVANCED AND
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE WITH IMPROVE
DIVERSITY WAGES AND HEALTH
EQUITY OUTCOMES. AND I FEEL
LIKE- YOU KNOW IS- WHERE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS ON ADDRESSING THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS IS
REALLY THE KEY COMPONENT OF
THIS. PARTICULAR INVESTMENT BUT
WELL. THIS IS YOU IS THIS YOUR
STATEMENT THIS IS NOT BEING
ADDRESSED BY THIS HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS GOING DR
JON MUCH RIGHT NOW. WELL A AND I
WAS GONNA ASK VOTE IT MIGHT TAKE
YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT THE WHAT
ONE THIRTY MILLION AS WE HAVE
THAT MUCH MONEY AVAILABLE SO
WE'RE JUST GONNA TOSS IT IN.
WITHOUT HAVING DONE ANY KIND OF
ANALYSIS OF THE DEMAND FOR THIS
THIS THIS FUNDING. BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU'RE MONITORING IT BUT
I'VE NOT HEARD YET AND I DON'T
MEAN TO BE HARSH BUT- I HAVEN'T
REALLY HEARD A JUSTIFICATION FOR
WHY THIS FUNDING IS NEEDED. AND
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY RESPONSE
PARTICULARLY TO THE ALEJO'S
CONCERNS ABOUT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE AN ACCESS WITH THIS PART OF
FUNDS- SO. IT MIGHT TAKE A
CORRECTLY THAT WE JUST THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION. THAT YOU
TOOK A HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS THERE OR IS
THERE SOME KIND OF MAN THAT YOU
SAW THAT. YOU JUSTIFY THIS
PARTICULAR NUMBER. I AM WHEN
WITH THE OF FLYING. SO FOR THE-
FOR THE L. A. O.'S. STATEMENT ON
ON THE DECLINING. WITH THE
DOLLAR. PROGRAM IT IT IS TRUE
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN. YOU KNOW
TRENDS OF DECLINING ENROLLMENT
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT HAVE BEEN
REALLY EXACERBATED BY THE COCA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AT THIS TIME
WE'RE STILL MONITORING THAT TIME
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IT BUT-
WE'RE NOT PROPOSING TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO THE CURRENT ADULT
EDUCATION- ALLOCATION MODEL OR
THE APPROPRIATION AT THIS TIME I
THINK WE- WE THINK- CHANGES THAT
WOULD. WOULD BE PREMATURE- AND
THE ADDITIONAL HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION THAT'S FOR THAT'S
PROPOSED FOR THIS PROGRAM- IT'S
AS MY COLLEAGUE- CHEN MENTIONED
IT'S TO ADDRESS. HEALTHCARE
SHORTAGES WHILE ALSO PROVIDING.
UPSKILLING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS- INTO.
A HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION IT'S
INTENDED TO BE SPENT OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD KIND OF.
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'LL SEE WITH
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE OTHER
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE
MENTIONING. EARLIER DURING THIS
HEARING- IT'S INTENDED TO BE
SEED FUNDING TO HELP. THESE
PROGRAMS WHERE. YOU KNOW.
EXPENDITURES LIKE EQUIPMENT- YOU
KNOW MIGHT BE NEEDED FOR- YOU
KNOW- FOR. FORCE OF THESE HEALTH
BOOKING AND OR- I APPRECIATE
THAT RESPONSE I AYE BUT I TAKE
IT THAT YOU. TO THE TO THE CORK
I ASK ABOUT TEN MIN AGO. I DO
HAVE A RESPONSE THEY ALEJO'S
CONCERNS THAT WE DON'T ACTUALLY
NEED THIS FUNDING AND YOU HAVE A
BASIS FOR THAT I TAKE IT THE
ANSWERS AT THIS TIME YOU DO NOT
HAVE ANY. DATA THAT WOULD
SUGGEST THIS FUNDING IS NEEDED.
YEAH I THINK. WE ARE TRYING TO.
INDICATE THAT THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATIONS FOR ADULT
EDUCATION. IS NEEDED FOR THAT
FOR THE PURPOSE FOR THE- FOR THE
CURRENT ADULT LEARNERS IN THE
STATE. I'M AND I WE'RE NOT IN A
POSITION AT THIS TIME TO YOU
KNOW- INSIST THAT THEY USE THEIR
EXISTING APPROPRIATIONS- FOR
THIS ADDITIVE PURPOSE OF THESE
HEALTH CARE PATHWAYS- ARE JUST
MAKE A COMMENT. AFTER THIS. I
JUST THINK THERE WAS A
DISCONNECT. IN THIS CONVERSATION
A. N. A. N. A. IT'S AMAZING THAT
WERE THE ONES THAT WANT. TO BE
THE ANALYTICAL ONES. YEAH YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE WERE LOVE TO- J.
DO THIS BUT I THINK. THE ROAD-
THE REAL QUESTION IS WITH THE
EXISTING FINANCES ARE THOSE
BEING ADEQUATE SPENT. HER DOES
INCLUDE THE NEED BEING MET FROM
THAT. OF PATRICK WE WITH
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND THEN
BASED ON THAT ANALYSIS WHAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY AFTER THAT
AND I STILL THINK. THERE'S AN
UNANSWERED QUESTION ABOUT WHY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN'T DO THE
HEALTH WORKER PART AS OPPOSED TO
THE- ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER
PARK SO. I'M JUST GOING TO.
SURRENDER ON THIS LINE OF
QUESTIONING AND EXPECT WE'VE
GOTTEN AS FAR AS WE'RE GOING TO
GET SO WE SHOULD JUST. DECLARE
THAT THOSE ARE OUR CONCERNS AND
WE HOPE THAT THERE WILL BE DATA.
OR SOMETHING THAT ADDRESSES THEM
CLEARLY BEFORE WE GET TO BACK.
OUR THERE ANY ADDITIONAL. ON THE
SIDE. I THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS JUST TIRED OUT. THIS IS A SO
OF ME THANK THIS PANEL WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. AND
AND THAT COMPLETES OUR
CONSIDERATION OF- OF THE FIVE
ISSUES AND WERE PREPARED TO MOVE
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT. AND OUR
WORK I'M GOING TO ASK IN A
MOMENT IF THERE'S PUBLIC COMMON
IN THE HEARING ROOM BUT LET ME
GO FIRST TO THE MODERATOR AND
WELCOME THE TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
JUST ASK IF YOU HAVE MANY PEOPLE
LINED UP FOR COMMENT. RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE- FOR YOU TO UP AND
THERE'S A TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN
PARTICIPANTS ON OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THEN I AM GOING
TO LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE. OF THE
N. IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT WE GET
TO A FEW MINUTES BEFORE. A OF
FOR NOON AND THEY'RE STILL A LOT
OF PEOPLE LINE UP WE MIGHT HAVE
TO CUT IT OFF BUT BASED ON WHAT
WE SEE I THINK WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE A MINUTE. AND MR
MODERATOR BEFORE I COME BACK TO
YOU I SEE TWO PEOPLE THAT ARE
INTERESTED. IN COMMENTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM SO WE WOULD TO TAKE
UP TO ONE MINUTE COMMENTS ON THE
ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE AGENDA
TODAY I WOULD WELCOME YOU TO
THE- TO THE PODIUM- MARC
ABSTAINED CALIFORNIAN BY MENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK AND
STATE BACK IN THE TWENTY PLUS
YEARS. OF MOST OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT I HAVE DEALT WITH HAVE BEEN
FUNDED UNDER AROUND THE STATE
HAVE BEEN FUNDED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP ACADEMY-
PROGRAM. OUR MONEY DISCUSSION AS
FAR AS AND DUAL ENROLLMENT ONE
THING THAT DID NOT COME IN AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. IS TO LOOK AT
REFORM AND EXPANSION OF THE
ARTICULATION AGREEMENT PROCESS.
A LOT OF THE BARRIERS THAT WERE
BRACED BY YOUR- WOULD BE MATT
INSTALLED WITH ARTICULATION
AGREEMENTS WITH EXPANSION REFORM
AND PROBABLY BE DUE TO THE-
GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND PROBABLY
ACCOMPLISHED AT LOWER COST. THE
TWO MAJOR REFORMS THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THE ARTICULATION-
AGREEMENT PROCESS. IS WITH TITLE
FIVE OF REMOVING THE LANGUAGE
THAT IS IN. THERE THIS UNDER AN
ARCTIC IF YOU AGREEMENT ARE NOW
FISHING DISPUTE UNLESS THEY GO
TO BED. COMMUNITY BECAUSE- I. IF
CREDITS WERE ISSUED OUT. WHEN MR
MAP REQUIREMENTS OF THE CRIED
THEY BECOME PORTABLE. AND A LOT
MORE ATTRACTIVE TO STUDENTS. THE
OTHER THING THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE
IS TO ALLOW THE HIGH SCHOOLS TO
MAKE AN ARTICULATION AGREEMENT
WITH ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ACROSS THE STATE. AS FAR AS A
LOT OF THE FUNDING I REQUEST I
HAVE A CYNICISM BASED UPON MY-
EXPERIENCE OF WATCHING THE SB
SEVENTY S. B. TEN SEVENTY.
PROCESS WHERE ARE HIDDEN AROUND
I HAD TO INTERRUPT YOUR CYNICISM
BUT ARE YOU I'VE LET YOU GO A
LITTLE WHILE OVER THE ONE MINUTE
AND IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS PLEASE OKAY COME TO THE
COMMITTEE OKAY OUT ONE BILLION
BASICALLY THAT THE UNDERLYING.
MEANT THAT WAS THE END OF. SO
YOU VERY AND YOU CAN. DISHMOK WE
HAVE A NO PERSON WHICH IS TO
ADDRESSES HERE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
SHAREWARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST- HERE TO
READ BUT- ADDRESS ONE B. SO IN
OUR MOST RECENT JUMP START DOING
ROMAN REPORT WE OUTLINED THE-
POWERFUL LEVEL LEVEL. ONE MOMENT
CAN BE IN CREATING MORE COLLEGE
CAREER PATHWAYS BETWEEN K.
TWELVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THAT
pBEING SAID WE ALSO CALLED OUT
SOME OF THE EQUITY GAPS THAT DO
EXIST. WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT THIS
INVESTMENT BUT ALSO BUILD AND
STRENGTHEN IN A FEW KEY WAYS.
FIRST THE L. L.'S RECOMMENDATION
ABOUT REVISITING THE L. E. A.
PRIORITIZE ATION METRICS SECOND
GOING ONE STEP FURTHER AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
FOR THE STUDENTS THAT SHOULD BE
TARGETED WITH ONE MOMENT. MORE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. ENSURING
THE DUAL CREDIT FOR DOING
ROAMING COURSES WHEN POSSIBLE SO
BOTH COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL
CREDITS. A TO ADDRESS A CENTER
WHICH WAS BOTH QUESTION ABOUT-
ONE OF THE BARRIERS-
COMMUNICATION AND MARKETING
PARENTS STUDENTS DON'T REALLY
KNOW ABOUT DOING WRONG AND WE
NEED TO. STRENGTHEN THAT AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO SUBMIT OTHER
COMMENTS TO YOUR CODE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADD TO YOUR STUFF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
US SAYING NO ONE ELSE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE. TO THE- TO THE- ART CON-
SYSTEM MODERATOR WELCOME BACK
AND FORGOT I'M GONNA LIMITED TO
ONE MINUTE PLEASE. T. UP THOSE
THAT ARE READY TO CONDUCT. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LAZY DUMB
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. REAL QUICKLY GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE THE PLACE
RIGHT BACK INTO THE QUEUE GOOD
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF
THESE- ISSUES PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH THE
LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND WEBER REALLY GREAT I WOULD
LIKE ALL. MY NINETEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE NINETEEN WELL MOVING
ALONG HELLO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM THAT I MEAN
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW PRECIADO PUBLIC HAS
ON ISSUE THREE THE LITERACY. HE
SUPPORTS LA RECOMMENDING AROUND
BY TO IDENTIFIED WELL PER PER
STUDENT SHE MET- ON ISSUE FOR
AND WORK TO PULL PLEASE THE
PROPOSED ABOUT MISTER TTC. AND
IN PARTICULAR THE FUNDING FOR
OUR TO HIGH THE BALLOT AND
BENEFITS EDUCATION CAREER IN
CALIFORNIA CREEK THROUGH GRADE
TWELVE. WE LIKE TO A IT PIE OF
NEW EDUCATE AND TO COMBAT
TEACHER ABOUT BY LEE TO MY AND
EAT ALL ENGLISH LEARNER TEACHER
AND DEVELOPMENT. REPORTER ARE
EXPANDING ACT TO ED AND THE FACT
ENGLISH LANGUAGE REQUIREMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR
CALL. THANK YOU FOR SEVEN PLEASE
GO AT. I MA'AM MANY JENNIFER
FONG OF ANY PUBLIC SCHOOLS AN
INMATE AND ACROSS THE STATE
BELIEVE THAT IN TO MEANING PRIME
ON FOR MARKET MORE ON THE ISSUE
OF THE BLACK. WE APPRECIATE THE
FOR FUND FOR THE NEW AT TRAINING
TOOL AND OTHER IT'S AND TASK
DRAFTING. BUT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FALLS SHORT IN FOUR TO
COMMITTED TO ADDRESS IN THE
READING. WE ASK OUR THAT THE
PLEDGE ENSURE THAT THE COMING
BUDGET INCLUDES AN MANDATE FOR
UNIVERSE CRANE FOR OF JUST.
USING LOW COST VALIDATED YOUR
SCREENING AND BETTER BE ABLE
RIGHT NOW UNIVERSAL PRE WILL
HELP WITH THE ELIMINATING IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AND WE YOU TO
INCLUDE DIFFERENT AS PART OF ANY
MOTOR PACKAGE THANK YOU SO. MUCH
THANK YOU AND WE USUALLY DON'T
COME. ON COMMON BUT- I WOULD
JUST MATCH THAT THERE WAS SAID.
OUR PROGRAM- OF REQUEST THAT WAS
IN ANOTHER HEARING WE HAD AND SO
THE LITERACY ISN'T STAND ALONE
ON THAT ISSUE BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. EXTRALITE TWENTY NINE YOUR
OPEN. I REMEMBER AS A CHAIR
THANK YOU SO THIS IS TIFFANY
MAKHOSI STA- THE UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND LYFT BY
PROFESSIONALS WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE WONDERFUL
DISCUSSION ON ALL THE TOPICS AND
JUST HIGHLIGHT QUICKLY- THAT
THAT WITH THE SHORTAGE OF STAFF
EMPLOYEES AT SCHOOLS BUT
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS THAT THE FOCUS ON
WAIVERS AND STREAMLINING I THINK
AND- DOESN'T ADDRESS SOME OF THE
COMPENSATION ISSUES THAT WE SEE
STATISTICALLY THAT FOR COLLEGE
GRADUATES IS THAT STARTING
SALARY 20% LESS THAN THE AVERAGE
SALARY AND THAT IF WE WANT TO
ATTRACT. A WONDERFUL WORKFORCE
WE REALLY NEED TO THE
PARTICULARLY TARGETING THOSE
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND
EXPERIENCES WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT COMPENSATION OF WHAT THIS
WOULD MEAN TO TRACK THOSE TO
THIS FIELD SECOND- TO THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION AROUND ADULT
EDUCATION FUND MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE BILL AND NOW HIS OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE JUST RELATED
BECAUSE IT EXPLAINS HOW. THE
FUNDS ARE NOT FULLY SPENT
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE DISTRIBUTED TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE THEY
ARE REVERTED BACK TO WHAT I
BELIEVE IS THE GENERAL FUND BUT
I'M NEW TO THIS AREA LOOK FOR
DISCUSSION HOPEFULLY GETTING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND CHAIR THE-
HELPFUL ANSWERS THEIR QUESTIONS
THAT THEY OPERATE THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR
NOW CALL. THANK YOU WILL GO
THIRTY. K. COMMITTEE MEMBER
BEING MAY TWENTY WITH COLLEGE
CAN TO BE AN FULL OF THE GUY
PROPOSED BY FOR ALL. NEED
COLLEGES FIFTEENTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOTOR NEXT. TWENTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. MISTER SHARON
MEMBER STAFF A LOT ON BEHALF OF
ANY PLACE WE DO APPRECIATE THE
PAST DISCUSSIONS ON THE PLANE
YEAH BUT YOU WANT TO REITERATE
THAT ANY LITERACY PROPOSAL
SHOULD CONSIDER AN APPROACH TO
THE FLAG YEAH WE ARE WAY BEHIND
AND THAT IS REFLECTED IN OUR
READING SCORES MAJEED MAGATH. IN
POLITICS LIKE HIS SPECTRUM
STRUGGLE EVERYDAY OFTEN WITHOUT
THE PROPER IDENTIFICATION AND
SUPPORT THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE UCSF DYSLEXIA
CENTER WHICH IS DEVELOPING A
SCREENING OUT FOR DYSLEXIA BUT
THAT AB IS YET TO BE VALIDATED
BOB THIS IS POSITIVE WE KNOW
THERE ARE MANY LOW COST
VALIDATED UNIVERSAL SCREENING
INSTRUMENTS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
THAT OTHER STATES. BUT YOU CAN
BRING YOUR- HERE IS A-
ADDRESSING THE RE CRISIS AND I
WILL. AND ABOUT. AND CAL COOL.
WHICH SHOULD BE MADE. UNIVERSAL
EARLY CORRECT OF THE- WITHOUT IT
MANY STUDENTS WE- WILL NOT BE I
. AND RICKY THE SUPPORT THE NEED
. UNIVERSE SCREENING OF THE LOW
COST INVESTMENT THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE COSTS TO
SCHOOLS AND FAMILIES. LATER
ACADEMIC REMEDIATION AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE PER
SHIFT. MODERATOR NEXT CALL. WHY
TWENTY FOUR ME I APOLOGIZE LINE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BIRD PAL HIGHLY
HERE TO SPEAK ON ONE EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CRESCENTA IF YOU
DOING POWERS AUTHORITY COALITION
IN ORDER. COMPRISED FOURTEEN
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS TO
DELIVER SPEAKING THE MORNING
SIXTIES DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SUPPORT THE MINISTER
WANTING TO INVEST MORE MONEY
INTO CREEK EDUCATE. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE FUNDING
BALANCES BOTH COLLEGE AND CAREER
READY NOW. OUR COALITION MEMBERS
DECADES SUCCESS PREPARING
STUDENTS FROM COLLEGE CAREER I
MEAN TO GET VITAL TO INVEST ANY
ADDITIONAL T. IT IS. PROGRAM
THAT SICK THAT EXISTING AND
GROWING HEALTH SKILL WORKFORCE
BY ESPECIALLY AS BIG OUT OF THE
SIDE OF THE PANDEMIC. AND FORTY
DESPITE THE YOU'RE THAT MOST
BERMAN WILL NOT BE WOULD BE TO
APPLY FOR THE WANT BILLION
DOLLAR GOLD ATHLETES IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. FOR THIS
REASON WE TO WORK WITH A LOT
MINUTES TO ENSURE THE TEAM AND
IN A THAT PATRICIA ALL. THAT THE
LONGEST OF THE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR-
MODERATOR NOT CALL. LINE THIRTY
SO PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHU MEMBER I'M NOT A THE WAY THE
CAL EDGE CHOLISH IN THE OF THE
FOR DUAL ENROLLMENT OP. WE ALSO
WAS- OUR LEADERS TO INCLUDE
ADULT LEARNERS AS PART OF THIS
AND BACK TO A IN. OF ALL THAT
ARE A TO ONE WILL BE. THE YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. WINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON CAP WITH
MCCUE CAME ASSOCIATES BEHALF CUT
CALIFORNIA TOLD EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION AND
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL HURDLE%
EDUCATION ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
RELATED TO THE FEW WINNERS FOR
CREDENTIALING AND EXAMS AT THE
STADIUM CARE PLEASE SUPPORT
THOSE I WOULD ONLY JUST OUT TO
ENSURE THAT THAT'LL EDUCATION
TEACHERS AND STAFF HAVE ACCESS
TO THE WAIVERS. NOT GIVEN THE
DAY TO ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
TEACHING CREDENTIALS THE
PROCESSING COST WHICH CAN BE A
BURDEN TO ENTRY FOR ADULT
EDUCATION IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM I'LL ALSO ON THE ISSUE OF
NUMBER FIVE RELATED TO THE
HEALTH CARE VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
FUNDING VIA EDUCATION PROGRAM
CCAD ANTI YEAR STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT FUNDING I WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATION- WITHOUT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF AND NUMBERS TO
ADDRESS OUR OUR PERSPECTIVES
RELATED TO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY. ON DECLINING ENROLLMENT
IN THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM OF WHICH
THE STADIUM CARE REPRESENTS THAT
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THE T.
PATHWAYS ARE A REALLY CRITICAL
ELEMENT OF THE WORK THAT HE
TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS YOU AND
MANY OF THEIR CLASSES AND
PROGRAMS HAVE WAIT LONG WAITING
LISTS SUCH THAT THIS TYPE OF
FUNDING WOULD HELP ENSURE
GREATER ACCESS FOR THESE
CRITICAL PATHWAYS ESPECIALLY ODD
GIVEN THE NEED THAT I IN THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR SO FOR THESE
REASONS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE TO GO AHEAD. YEAH MISTER
BIRTH NECRO CALLED ON BEHALF THE
MIKE SINCE PAPA POLICY JUST ONE
EXPRESS STARTS FOR THE COULD BY
HUNDRED DOLLARS BACK INTO WRONG
PROGRAM THANK SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE THIRTY
ONE- YOU ARE UP. THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO. YOU'RE
WRONG. WELL MY NAME IS LATER
FROM FUTURE LEADERS OF AMERICA
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
ONE B. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN EXPANDING
DUAL ENROLLMENT- I WOULD SUPPORT
EXPANDING TO OUR ONLY BECAUSE
IT'S QUITE ACTIVE AFFORDABILITY
THINK THAT- WE JUST WANTED TO
ECHO ADDRESS WHAT OF- MAKING
SURE THAT OF COLOR HAVE ACTUALLY
HE ACTORS TO DO OUR OWN TO
REPEAT CRITICAL BUT AS WELL AND
WE'LL GO TOWARDS IT THAT
EDUCATION ACT AND RACIAL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMMENTS MODERATOR MEXICO. WE
WILL I TWENTY FIVE. YOU OPEN. HI
I'M MEGAN PORTENT CAUSED
DIRECTOR FOR THE DYSLEXIA. A
GRASSROOTS THAT TO IMPROVING OUT
FOR THE WITH DISPLAY AND ALL
STRUGGLES LITERACY. I'M COMING
TODAY ON ISSUE TO THE STATE
WOULD RECEIVE HER. WE READ THAT
THE GUY BY AND GREEK UNIVERSE
FREE FOR READ REST IN CAN.
THROUGH SECOND GRADE. EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND INTERVENTION
ARE NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
CALIFORNIA READING CRISIS.
UNIVERSAL FEES ASK GREENING IS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN
DETERMINING WHICH STUDENTS ARE
AT RISK FOR READING DIFFICULTY
INCLUDING DYSLEXIA. THE MAJORITY
OF STATES ALREADY REQUIRE
UNIVERSAL SCREENING FOR READING
REST UTILIZED. LOW COST BRIEF
SCREENING TOOL WILL PROVIDE
EDUCATORS WITH IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ON WHERE TO TARGET
INSTRUCTION IN THE EARLY GREAT.
READ DATA SHOW THAT OUR YOUNGEST
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN THE MOST
IMPACTED BY COLIN LEARNING LIFE
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT K<c.cyan></c>
STUDENTS ARE RELIABLY SCREEN FOR
READING REST. WE ASK THAT
REQUIRED UNIVERSAL SCREENING BE
ADDED TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. ONE THIRTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. I THANK YOU CARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS DOCTOR
MALANDA AND I'M CALLING
REPRESENTING HEALTHCARE RESOURCE
CENTER AND WE FOR OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THE LOS
ANGELES AND SAMPOERNA DINO
COUNTY AREA WE ARE CALLING-
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ON
EDUCATED WORKFORCE AND WHILE
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB
RECRUITING AND DEVELOPMENT AND
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR THE
WORKFORCE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AND EARLY EDUCATION SPENDING BOB
HOPE PRESCHOOL AND TKA-
EDUCATORS WHO ARE PART OF THE
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL SYSTEM HAVE
ACCESS. TO- AT AFTER CHU
CREDENTIAL PER THAT ARE OUT
PREPARE THEM TO BE WITH THE
CHILDREN THERE BY ASKING THAT AT
LEAST TWENTY FOUR UNITS ARE
PROVIDED FOR ALL THOSE WHO WORK
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN I RECENTLY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT OUR
CHILDREN- THERE ARE FAR BETTER-
THE ODD BIT WITH THOSE WHO HAVE
. BEEN PREPARED WITH THE USING
TWENTY FOUR UNITS OF EARLY
EDUCATION AND MORE AND WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
AT PRESCHOOL ALIGNMENT- FOR P.
THREE THREE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
AND ITHOUT THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT OUR CHILDREN WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO DEVELOPMENTS. WE
APPROPRIATE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MONTEREY NEXT CALL.
WINDS SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JULIAN CLEVERNESS AND ON BEHALF
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND TO A MOMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. WE WILL ALIGN THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANY COMPELLING EVIDENCE
IN FUTURE YEARS OF AMERICA I'M
ALSO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
FACT YEAH WE INVEST. EXPAND ON
ROMANTIC PROVIDE ARE YOU PUT
MORE TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND
ALL COULD BE BETTER PREPARED FOR
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSEWORK I THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. ONE THIRTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. I THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SERENA LAND I'M FROM EDUCATE
RICHMOND SYSTEM AND I AM GOING
TO ROUTE WHAT I SAID YESTERDAY-
DURING THE T. K. U. P. K.
HEARING THAT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
STAR CLIPPER AND THE HIGHEST
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS
INVESTING IN CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AFTER. URGENT EMERGING
ISSUE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FROM THE ROLL OUT OF BEAUTY CAN
YOU P. K. MUST BE ADDRESSED THE
ONE A ONE B. AND ISSUE TO TOTAL
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION FUNDING
AND MORE HONESTLY SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO CHILDREN ZERO TWO
YEARS OF AGE AND THE WOMEN OF
COLOR THE THIRD THEM AND THE NON
ELLIE A COMMUNITY BASED MAKE
LIVER WITH THEM. NEARLY THREE
QUARTER OF THE G. CATER
EDUCATORS ARE WHITE COMPARED TO
THE DIVERSE NON LED GIVER FORTY
PER OF WHOM ARE WOMEN OF COLOR
THESE WOMEN OF COLOR ON AVERAGE
ARE PAID HALF OF G. K. WHITE
TWELVE THE G. CATER TO A WHITE
WORK FORCE. MOREOVER ONLY 14% OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO INTERNET HOW THE CARE OF THE
MOTHER OF A TWO YEAR OLD AND A
FIVE YEAR OLD I CAN AGREE THAT
THIS IS THE CASE AND MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE SYSTEM MATCH
THAT OF THE DATA CALIFORNIA
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE ANYMORE
FAMILY AND CHILD CARE CENTERS. I
CHALLENGE THE FISCAL DEPARTMENT
ALYOKHINA SEVENTY EITHER ANSWER
THE FOLLOWING HOW MUCH WOULD IT
COST TO MATCH THE B. STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE TO THE BASE HE K.
ABA RATE WHY DO WE CONTINUE TO
FIND REMEDIAL EDUCATION INSTEAD
OF THE FOUNDATION NEEDED FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN TO
SUCCEED. WHY DO WE CONTINUE TO
IMPOVERISH THE WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE AS WE SPEAK I'VE. I'VE GOT
YOU. ARE THERE OVER THE WIN
THANK YOU FOR YOU FOR LETTING ME
YEAH I AGREE THAT MY NEXT CALL.
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR- OPEN. I
REMEMBER THAN CARE THINKING FOR
YOUR TIME NAME IS THAT YOU OFF
FROM A FOR BETTER. BROWN LAW THE
ADVANCES SOCIAL RACIAL AND INTO
FOR THE ENOUGH TO AND HOW THEY
AND ALI REGENCY PARK AND HAD.
AND GRANTS OF THE FIVE NEWMAN
DOLLAR INVESTMENT BIG FAN WILL
IMPLEMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON NECK CALL. WE WILL
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO J.
AB MEMBERS MY NAME IS IN OKAY IF
I AM ONE HUNDRED FUTURE LEADERS
OF AMERICA AND TODAY I LIKE TO
SUPPORT YOUR SUPPORT.
CREDIT RATING AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS OUR MODERATOR WHEN
HE STARTED THIS YOU SAID THERE
WERE EIGHTEEN PEOPLE ON AND THAT
WAS OUR EIGHTEENTH CALLER HOW
MANY MORE ARE IN QUEUE WELL. WE
GOT UP TO LIKE TWENTY TWO WERE
DOWN TO THREE NOW THEN WE'LL
TAKE THOSE THREE AND CALL IT A
DAY SO MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
CAN HEAR YOU WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD WERE WELCOME IN YOUR
TESTIMONY AND. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY NAME IS THAT NOTHING
BE ALIGNED WITH THE TRIMMING
ECONOMIC I'M CALLING FOR AND I
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT BIG FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- PROVIDING A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO OUT THE HIGH
SCHOOL CAREER THAT THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL YEARS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. BY FORTY TO PLAY GO AHEAD
. HELLO TURN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
MELISSA VIEWPOINT THAT POLICY
ASSOCIATE WITH FUTURE YEARS OF
AMERICA AND I'M ALSO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE B. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENT TO EXPAND
TOOL AND- ENROLLMENT THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND MODERATOR THE SHOULD BE OUR
LAST CALL. WE WILL BETTER ALIGN
THIRTY FOUR TO WRAP THINGS UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS BANDSTAND PREVALENCE OF
THE LINK LEARNING ALLIANCE. MORE
THAN TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS IN DUAL ENROLLMENT
CRITICAL INVESTMENT IN YOUTH
AGES FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR IN
CALIFORNIA MANY ARE
DISCONNECTING FROM LEARNING IN
THEIR POTENTIAL DURING THE-FORMATIVE TIME AND WITH THE
REALITY THAT. ENDEMIC OUR STATE
AND OUR ECONOMY CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE ALLEN IN COLLEGE YOU LATE
THE PARK. LAND INVESTMENT BUILD
ON OUR EXISTING PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE AND CAREER WHILE
BRINGING COMMUNITIES TOGETHER
AROUND A. COMMON VISION OF. THAT
I YOUNG PEOPLE WITH REGULAR
RELEVAN THE- WITH THE NEWS
SECONDARY. BELIEVE FOR HIGH
OPPORTUNE CAREER WITH. STANDING
WAITING. MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTY ARE NOT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE. THESE BUDGET SHOULD
BE COULD WITH FUNDING SOURCES
BUDGET BACON CALLED THE MARK
REALIZED VISION FOR ABOUT. THE
TIME IS NOW TO EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THOUSAND MORE
AND BRING HOPE HERE IN AND- THE
JOURNEY FROM TWELVE WE WENT
QUALITY CAREER. THIS BUDGET CAN
MAKE IT HAPPEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WE APPRECIATED AND MODERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE TODAY. IN NAVIGATING
ALL THE PEOPLE THE COLD WE
APPRECIATED. THAT COMPLETES THE
BUSINESS IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED. IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFIED TODAY OR YOU HAD
YOUR COMMENTS CUT SHORT BY A
TIME LIMIT. A PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. OF WHO
THEY ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY.
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
I IT'S ALL THANKS TO HAVE. FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND CO. NOT JUST
THIS BUT IN THE PRECEDING EIGHT
ONES. THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
LAST FOUR AND A HALF WEEKS WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEWS SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.
ALL.